COMMUNICATIONS WE WILL NOW COME
TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY HAD TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH ONE OF OUR COMMITMENT
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
ARM MEMBER ATTENDING REMOTELY.
TODAY IS SENATOR STERN. IF
CENTER STERN IS VERY UPSET
PLEASE- I DON'T YOURSELF ANY OF
YOUR STUFF THAT MIGHT BE
PARTICIPATING WITH YOU. EGGMAN
CHAIR MY STAFF HERE IT MIGHT
REC JEREMY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AND SENATOR IS THROUGH MY
PLEASED YOUR MEET YOUR FOR OR-
THIS WILL GREATLY ALLOW IN
EIGHTY ELEVEN OF A COST FEED. I
ETCETERA TIME YOU WISH TO BE.
USED TO RAISE HAND FEATURING
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT YOUR MUTE- BUT
BEFORE. YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R.
I. T. WILL PUT HIM BACK ON MUTE
WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS WILL
ALLOW. AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE WHO INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SIX FIVE SEVEN.
TWO NINE FIVE SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES THAT WORKS.
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER
AT THAT TIME. YOU WILL BE UN
MUTED AND YOU ARE NOT READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
pHEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT A HEARING CHEN IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNERS
CUSTOMER IS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME LIKE TIMES FOR
PARTICIPATING WHO. FOR JUSTIN
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO. ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
HE. WE HAVE A BILLS ON TODAY A
S. B. SEVEN FORTY BY SENATOR
BORJAS AND S. SIXTY SEVEN- BY
BECKER HAVE BEEN PULLED FROM
FROM THE AGENDA BY THE AUTHORS
WE WOULD LIKE TO ADVISE
EVERYONE DUE TO TIME
CONSTRAINTS SHOULD THE NEED
ARISE WE MAY LIMIT THE
TESTIMONY TO FIFTEEN MINUTES
FOR EACH SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
TO A BILL WE WILL LIMIT
ORGANIZED PRESENTATIONS TO
THREE MINUTES SO IF THERE WERE
MORE THAN- ONE SPEAKER WE WILL
DIVIDE UP THAT TIME BETWEEN THE
SPEAKERS ON EACH SIDE. BEFORE
WE HEAR THE PRESENTATION ON
BILLS WITH ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL-
WESSEL. PRESENT HER WITH A
PRESS. BY STERN DAILY. HERE BY
SISTER DOLLY HERE. SENATOR
BAKER THERE. BAKER HERE.
FORGE'S FURTHER FOR JUST
PRESENT. BRADFORD USER BRADFORD
HERE. THE HERE DOT HERE EGGMAN
HERE BASEMENT HERE CONCERT.
HERE GONZALEZ. GROW HURTS.
MCGUIRE. MAN YEAH IN HERE RUBIO.
STERN YOUR NAME. TERRY HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU THE MAN
CONSULTANT THE COOKING OF THE
CONSULTANT NOTES A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED WE HAVE ONE
BILL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR S.
B. SEVEN THREE THREE CAN I
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT ITEMS SENATOR DODD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THE MOTION
IS TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SB SEVEN THREE THREE-
MMHM. MONICA COULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SB SEVEN THREE
THREE BY SENATOR WESSEL TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL. HI
WESEL EINE DOLLY HI DALY HI
BAKER. HI BACK HI. ORDER ARE
LARGEST I BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI.
DOT GARDAI ARE HI EGGMAN I
EGGMAN I GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ HI
GROSS. HERTZBERG MCGUIRE. MAN
HI MAN I. RUBIO STERN. STERN
AYE STERN AYE. THANK YOU WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OF THE TRAPS OF
MEMBERS NEVER GONNA HEAR OFF
FOR MY FIRST AUTHOR CENTER PER
PORTANTINO TO PRESENT OUR FIRST
BILL SB SIX TWELVE WELCOME
CENTER PORTANTINO THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. AS THE CHAIR
MENTION I'M PRESENTING SP SIX
TWELVE WHICH ENSURES A FAIR AND
EQUAL ACCESS TO THE BENEFITS OF
LEGACY CONTRACT RESOURCES FOR
ALL CUSTOMERS AND ENSURES THAT
I OWE YOU PORTFOLIOS ARE
MANAGED TO MAXIMIZE VALUE AND
REDUCE UNNECESSARY COSTS FOR
ALL CUSTOMERS I WANT TO BEGIN-BY ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND THANK HIM
COMMITTEE IN THE CHAIR AND HIS
STAFF. FOR WORKING WITH MY
STAFF ON THIS MEASURE. TO BRING
US TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY. ANY
LIKE CITY PA. AND CAL WERE.
YEARS AGO. WHEN INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES- PREPARE THE
PREDOMINANT PROVIDER OF ENERGY
DO NOT REFLECT CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT LANDSCAPE. NO LONGER DO
THE BALL CALIFORNIANS THE BULK
OF CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE POWER
FROM THE BIG THREE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES- PGD SEVEN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND SAN DIEGO
GAS AND ELECTRIC. IN FACT OVER
THE LAST DESK DECADE MORE THAN
ELEVEN MILLION PEOPLE IN MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED CITIES AND
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE. HAVE
TRANSITIONED TO COMMUNITY
CHOICE AGGREGATION OR CCS. C.
NOW OCT ONE THIRD. OF THE
ORIGINAL I OWE YOU FOOT PRINT
AND APPROXIMATELY 50% OF PG'S
ORIGINAL SERVICE TERRY ALONE IS
NOW- IT ALONE AND THAT NUMBER
IS EXPECTED TO GROW
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE. MOST OF YOU
HAVE CCA'S IN YOUR DISTRICT AND
IF YOU DON'T. I CAN GUARANTEE
YOU THERE YOUR COMMUNITIES ARE
CONSIDERING IT. COMBINED THE
CCA TRANSITION WITH THE
EXPANSION OF DIRECT ACCESS WE
HAVE VERY DIFFERENT LANDSCAPE
THAN WE DID JUST A DECADE AGO
ONE POLICY AREA. THAT IS
OUTDATED AND REQUIRES IMMEDIATE
ATTENTION BECAUSE OF ITS IMPACT
ON RATEPAYERS HIS LEGACY ENERGY
RESOURCES. AS PART OF THE
TRANSITION TO A CCA CUSTOMERS
MUST SHARE IN THE COST
RESPONSIBILITY WITH HIGHER YOU
CUSTOMERS FOR I OWE YOU
GENERATION AND ELECTRIC.
ELECTRICITY SUPPLY CONTRACTS
ENTERED INTO BY- YOU I- USE
PRIOR TO CCA CUSTOMERS
DEPARTURE FOR CCA SERVICE.
POLICY CUSTOMERS MUST PAY THEIR
FAIR SHARE OF THE CONTRACTS AT
ISSUE SEVERAL YEARS AGO THEY DO
NOT HAVE FAIR ACCESS TO THE
FULL RANGE OF BENEFICIAL
RESOURCES THESE CONTRACTS
PROVIDE. THOSE BENEFITS ARE
RETAINED BY THE AYE YOU USE FOR
THEIR CUSTOMERS. AS A RESULT
CCA CUSTOMERS MUST TURN TO
INCREASINGLY SCARCE MARKETS. TO
PROCURE RESOURCES TO SERVE
THEIR CUSTOMERS WHY I OWE YOU
CUSTOMERS HAVE A FULL PORTFOLIO
OF RESOURCES AT THEIR DISPOSAL
RESOURCES THAT ARE SUBSIDIZED
BY CCA CUSTOMERS. THERE SIMPLY
IS NO GOOD POLICY RATIONALE FOR
THIS INEQUITABLE TREATMENT OF
CCA CUSTOMERS VERSUS I. O. U.
COUNTERPARTS. SO HOW DOES THIS
BILL FIX THIS INEQUITY SB SIX
TWELVE SIMPLY PROVIDES FAIR AND
EQUAL ACCESS TO THE BENEFITS OF
LEGACY RESOURCES AND CONTRACTS
FOR ALL CUSTOMERS. AND ENSURES
THAT I OWE YOU PORTFOLIOS ARE
MANAGED TO MAXIMIZE VALUE AND
REDUCE UNNECESSARY COSTS FOR
ALL CUSTOMERS SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL PROVIDES CUSTOMERS EQUAL
ACCESS TO LEGACY PRODUCTS THAT
THEY ARE PAYING FOR. THE
PROPORTION. TO WHAT THEY'RE
PAYING NOW. IT REQUIRES I OWE
YOU. TEN CELL ANY REMAINING
ACCESS LEGACY PRODUCTS NOT
TAKEN BY CUSTOMER TO THE WHOLE
MARKET AND LASTLY REQUIRES CPU
TO RECOGNIZE THE OF H. FREE
ENERGY IN THE SAME WAY
RENEWABLE ENERGY- PRODUCTS ARE
RECOGNIZED. BEFORE I GO TO MY
WITNESSES I. OB OBVIOUSLY WANT
TO THANK A NUMBER OF FOLKS
WHO'VE BEEN HELPING US GET TO
THE POINT WE'RE AT TODAY-
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION LARGE
SCALE SOLAR ASSOCIATION. AND
THE AMERICAN PLANE POWER
ASSOCIATION THE LARGEST TRADE
ASSOCIATION OF ENERGY
DEVELOPERS IN CALIFORNIA FOR
HIGHLIGHTING THEIR CONCERNS
EARLY IN THE PROCESS AND
WORKING WITH US TO RESOLVE
THOSE ISSUES BEFORE THE BILL
REACHED THIS COMMITTEE. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE MANY
CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP REPRESENTING
MANY LARGE BUSINESSES AND
ENERGY USERS AND MANY OTHERS
WHO HAVE- WHO UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF SB SIX TWELVE AND FOR
SUPPORTING THE BILL. WITH THAT
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU TO
TWO WITNESSES WILL BE
TESTIFYING HERE ON BEHALF AND
HERE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
MAY HAVE I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
TEN TED PARK. BARTEK EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CLEAN POWER
ALLIANCE AND SAM TANG THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER PIONEER
COMMUNITY ENERGY AND WHEN
APPROPRIATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL BE A BIG WITH THE LEAD
SUPPORT PRESNT WHICH GOING TO
BE A- OF THREE MINUTES. SPEAK
WHAT HAVE A MID A HALF BEGIN.
WITH TED PARTY. IF TEND BAR. ON
PHONE. YES I AM THANK. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS. MY NAME
IS TED PARTY AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CLEAN POWER
ALLIANCE. CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
COMMUNITY CHOICE AGGREGATION
PROGRAM SERVING OVER THREE
MILLION CUSTOMERS AND
BUSINESSES COSTS L. A. AND THEN
TURN COUNTY. WELL- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TO THE A LOT OF ISSUES
THAT IS THAT'S TO SEE PEOPLE
COME. AND INDEED THE ELEVEN
MILLION CUTS ACROSS TO HUNDRED.
AND CAL WHO ARE CERTAIN. DCX.
SORRY I'M GETTING A LITTLE BIT
OF THE SPEED SO TRUE MY. OKAY
FONG. I DO WANT TO THE WHAT
WHAT'S YOUR PORTANTINO'S SANTA
ON THE SB. SIX TWELVE. ABOUT
HALF. YOU'VE GOT NO BEEF.
HOWEVER THE LEGACY PERSISTS
DON'T GENERATE. WE'RE NORMAL
AND HOUSE GAS FOR ENERGY A
LITTLE. FOR BUT OUR CUSTOMERS
HELLO OF SYSTEMATIC ACTS. TO
DESPITE PAYING FOR THE- WHEN
CREATING IS THE LET A RECORD AS
BOAT OFF THAT **** ALLOCATED.
RIGHT REQUIRED TO IT FIRST.
AFTERNOON CARE QUITE SO BY. MY
NAME'S CHANG AND I'M TO OPERATE
OFFICER TIGER COMEDIAN. SILICON
VALLEY FEEDBACK AS WELL- SO I
JUST TO POINT OUT THAT B. C.
TWELVE BRING TO ALL CUSTOMER AS
A LEGISLATOR HM MANDATED BY
PROVIDING OF ALL LOW ARE WE GET.
THAT COULD HAVE ACCESS RESOURCE
THEY ARE ALREADY FOR THE PGA.
WITHOUT THIS BILL THE G. P. SEE
WILL. THE COST FROM THE O. U.'S
CUTS TO KEEP YOUR CUSTOMERS.
ALL RIGHT POINT OUT TO ME
DIRECT TO PIONEER. FIRST IN A
THREE YEAR PERIOD. PIONEER'S
CUSTOMERS BUT THAT THE- CLOCK
OVER NEXT DOWNTURN THREE. AND
NINE HUNDRED INTO THIRTEEN TO
THIRTEEN. AMOUNTING TO NEARLY
2% OF A TYPE PIE RESIN CUTS
TOTAL ELECTRO BILL. EITHER PINE
NOR OF ITS- RECEIVE THEIR SHARE
THE BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT. COMBINED RISING ENERGY.
DRIVEN BY PASSED SHORTAGE AS
BUT BY THE- IN AUGUST LAST. I
HAVE NO RIGHTS TO THE STATE
BENEFIT. DO YOU HAVE EXCEPT FOR
THREE DOLLARS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE WILL NOW MOVE TO SET
UP A SPEAKERS IN FAVOR AND IF
WE ASK THAT YOU LIMIT. YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR YOUR POSITION
AND SUPPORT HERE- NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION IF ANY SO IF THERE
IS ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
WILLING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX TWELVE. ANYONE WILL GO
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE ANYBODY ROOM
TWELVE. NO ONE THERE SO WE'LL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX TWELVE. THANK YOU SIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK AT THE PORT OF SB
SIX TWELVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TWENTY FIVE IN
Q. OF THE GALE OF WIND EIGHT.
ONE NINETY THREE. WHY NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS DOESN'T MATTER WHAT THE
CLIMATE CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT THE NEXT AMOUNT TO MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. SHKRELI SHOULD CREATE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE WERE DISTURBED BY THE END
OF THE CLEAN ENERGY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NEXT BAKER. ONE ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JONATHAN CLAY
ABOUT THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO IN
THE SENATE AND THE NEED TO
SUPPORT US SIX. NEXT BIGGER.
LINE ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY CONTRA
COSTA MARIN AND YELLOW ON
SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWELVE THANK
YOU. NEXT BIGGER. NINE ONE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TOLD ME IN THE LEAST
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AT
THE SANTA MONICA AND BEVERLY
HILLS IN SUPPORT ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
THE COUNTIES OF BUTTE AND AFTER
AND ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN THE
OFFICE OF MAYOR LONDON BREED
ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
BIGGER. NINE ONE THREE TWO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARK-SPENCER BAKER FOR VALLEY CLEAN
ENERGY AND PENINSULA CLEAN
ENERGY AND STRONG SUPPORTER OF
SB SIX TWELVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU THE NEXT SPEAKER. LINE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO EMILY PAPPAS WITH
ANYMORE IN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF
OF M. C. E. AS WELL AS THE
PRETTY ABOUT ME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. ONE ONE
FOUR FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
I THINK YOU ARE THE RETIRED
JACKSON CRUISE STRATEGIES ON
BEHALF OF SAN MATEO COUNTY
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT BIGGER.
NINE ONE FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JUSTIN
ARE FROM BILL CONNELLY
LEADERSHIP GROUP ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. LINE ONE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MISTER CAREY MEMBERS DON
GILBERT ON BEHALF OF CLEAN
POWER ASSETS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. NINE
ONE FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. A BATH ON BEHALF OF THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE TO NOTE
THAT WE HAVE GONE TO TRIAL ON
THE BALLOT I THINK THE AUTHOR
AND STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US
TO ADDRESS OUR INSURANCE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. ONE
ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU CARE CENTERS OR
NASTY WITH THE WITH THE WHITE
MAN GROUP ON BEHALF OF EAST BAY
COMMUNITY ENERGY AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. WHY ONE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS KURT HAMMOND FROM SAN
DIEGO ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. KENNECOTT. THREE FIFTY
THOUSAND BALLY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. A LINE ONE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROGER
DICKINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
NINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON STEP BY.
OUR AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JOSE
TRINIDAD CAPTAIN GHETTO WITH
CLIMATE ACTION CAMPAIGN ACROSS
ORANGE COUNTY AND SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
WINE ONE FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HOW MANY AND HARVEY
IN OAKLAND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. LINE ONE
TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MARINO WHICH SAN JOSE
COMMUNITY ENERGY ADVOCATES IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. ONE ONE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MICHAEL
OUT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS COUNTY
SANTA CLARA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THIRTEEN HER CALLING IN TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
THE VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. ONE ONE TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX ONE TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. ONE
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. CHARLES RIGHT ON BEHALF
OF CAL CHOICES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SIX ONE
TWO. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. ONE
ONE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KENAPA KALAU YET FROM AN
ACCIDENT SUPPORT OF THAT THE TO
CONTINUE. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
NEXT OPEN NINE ONE ZERO THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK
YOU IS A PRIME EXAMPLE
REPRESENTING CENTRAL COAST
COMMUNITY ENERGY SUPPORTING SB.
SIX THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER.
CLICK TO OPEN MY NUMBER ONE
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. ONE ONE FIFTY EIGHT. THIS
IS A DAVID MCCORD AND THEM CAN
LIVE IN EL SERENO AND THEN.
TYPICALLY A FAVOR- AND THIS
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
WHITE ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO CANNOT ALLOW YOU
TO COME ACTION IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX ONE TWO. THANK YOU NEXT
BECAUSE. LEVINE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SENATE
CHAMBERS SILICON VALLEY CLEAN
ENERGY IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. BEFORE WE OPEN
ONE ONE SIXTY TWO ABOUT THE
REMINDER IF ANYONE AT THE PORT
OF STILL SB SIX ONE TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
ONE SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CARE OFF
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY IT'S A
LOT OF BEACH IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER
AFTER ONE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
AT THE TIME SIR. WILLIAM RIGHT
HERE THIS ALL SUPPORTER AND.
WHAT WRITER THERE ANYMORE IN
THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT. NO FIVE
NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORT. OKAY WE WILL GO TO
LEAD OPPOSITION. WHICH IS
RACHEL COSTS. GOOD AFTERNOON
HONORABLE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE RACHEL KAUFMAN
BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION THE STORM
ABOUT THE PCHR KEEPS NECESSARY
TO ENSURE A BUNDLE UTILITY
CUSTOMERS DON'T PAY MORE
BECAUSE THE PC EIGHT. UTILITIES
CHARACTER FOR CUSTOMERS WHO
THEN LAST UTILITY PROCUREMENT
SERVICES FOR CCA SERVICE
ANOTHER CUSTOMERS TO REMAIN
WITH UTILITY PROCUREMENT
SERVICE SHOULD NOT HAVE TO PAY
MORE BECAUSE OF THAT AND THAT'S
WHY THERE IS THE PPA CHARGE AND
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT UTILITY
SHAREHOLDERS DO NOT MAKE
PROFITS OR INCUR ANY LOSS FROM
THE PPA CHARGE. ALL ABOUT WHICH
CUSTOMERS PAY. FOR THE ALREADY
PICTURED ENERGY. AS RIGHT IN
THIS MANDATE THE COSTS BE SURE.
IF YOU CUSTOM. ABOUT W. TWO
COSTS THIS IS. UNACCEPTABLE
UNEX. THE BELMONT BE AMEND INTO
WAY. FOR THE FIFTEENTH LONG
COME THAT HE UTILITIES OVER PER
WHICH TO PLAY A KEY A CHARGE
ANI SHOULD BE FOR TO GET RID OF
RESOURCE. THE TNC JEFF ISSUED A
OF THE ON THE TOPIC WITH WOULD
REDUCE THE TO. ACCESSORIES FOR
THOSE RESOURCES THAT ARE NOT
NEEDED SERVE CUSTOMERS OR- TO
BE COMPLIANT CHIU. WHAT WOULD
THE PCA CHARGE BUT THE CCA'S R.
NOT HAPPY WITH THE PC DECISION
AND THEY WANT THE LEGISLATURE
TO MANDATE THAT I USE GET RID
OF MORE P. C. I. A. PORTFOLIO
REQUIRES THAT. WHETHER THEY ARE
ACCESS OR NOT THIS WOULD
INCREASE THE BILL THE BUNDLE
UTILITY CUSTOMERS BECAUSE I'LL
USE WOULD THEN HAVE TO PUT YOUR
MORE RESOURCES. TO MEET ANY
SHORTFALL. THEREFORE CORRECT
THE WM. ACCESS RESTORE TO
RESOURCES WHICH ARE ONLY OUR PS
THREE. THANK THE CPA'S ALSO.
THAT THE VALUE GIVEN TO G. H.
FREE RESOURCE IN THE P.
CALCULAR IS TO. THE VALUE IS
CURRENTLY BASED ON PRICE THE
PAID ACTUAL MARKET TRANSACTIONS
BUT THE CPA'S WANTING HIGHER
HERE READ THE FULL BALLY FOR
GHG FREE RESOURCES SO THEY CAN
INCREASE THE PCIE CHARGE. THE
PST PREVIOUSLY AND APPROPRIATED
APPROPRIATELY REJECTED THIS
APPROACH BUNDLED UTILITY
CUSTOMERS SHOULD NOT PAY A
PREMIUM FOR SOME OF THE RADICAL
VALUE OF GHG FREE RESOURCES
THAT. ARE NOT RELIABLE IN THE
MARKET. THANKS FOR THE BILL
SHOULD ALSO BE AMENDED
TERMINATE THE TO REQUIRE THE P.
SEE TO DIE THAT FOR G. H.
RESOURCE. BASED ON ANYTHING
OTHER HAN ACTUAL MARKET
TRANSACTIONS. I'VE WRITTEN THE
BILL AND UP IN THE BILL. A
BUNDLE CUSTOMER BECAUSE A FEW.
WHAT ABOUT THEREFORE WE HAVE TO
OPPOSE THE BILL AS AMENDED BUT
THEY JUST DESCRIBED IN THE-
PROTECT. YOU TO CUTS. WE
APPRECIATE THE CAN WORK ON THE
BALLOT WE WILL THEM AND THEN
ACCEPTED TODAY AND WE THANK
AUTHOR CAN TO WORK WITH. THANK
YOU VERY. THANK YOU NOW WILL GO
TO WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY.
SEEING NONE- WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE SITTING NINE
MODERATOR NOW WE WILL GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- SB SIX
TWELVE. PLEASE BRING THEM UP IN
THE QUEUE. CERTAINLY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
TWELVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. JERRY MEMBERS INJURED
COACH AMERICAN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON. SPECTRUM
OPPOSED TO U. S. B. SIX TWELVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
THEY'RE CURRENTLY WITH OPERATOR.
FLEXIBLE TO LINE ONE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS GIVING A
FUNDING FROM BEHALF OF PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC COMPANY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ANNEX TO OPEN MY NUMBER
NINETY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
TELLING THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. AND AS A
REMINDER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE- SB SIX
TWELVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION. THE
MODERATOR WILL NOW BRING IT
BACK TO MEMBERS. WE HAVE.
MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
SENATOR GONZALEZ THANK THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- MET WITH MANY OF
THE ALLIANCES WITHIN MY
DISTRICT THAT SERVE PARAMOUNT
AND AN INTERPRETIVE A SOUTH LOS
THAT HE BROUGHT THE SPORT AND I
WILL MOVE WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU- SENATOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU- AND TO THE AUTHOR I.
I HAVE A I HAVE A MIXED
PORTFOLIO IN MY DISTRICT AND I
AM I AM. I'VE HEARD FROM SOME
AND I'M STILL WAITING HEREBY
FROM OTHERS NUMBERS SUPPORT
THIS TODAY BUT I WANT TO
RESERVE MY RIGHT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. SEE TO SEE HOW IT
IMPACTS. I MEAN I UNDERSTAND
BUT IT ALSO SOUNDS LIKE THOSE.
ON REGULAR UTILITIES THEIR
PRICES WILL GO UP AS IS MY
LARGEST CITY THANK. I THINK
CENTER HERTZBERG. K. AS USER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SURE
YEAH I JUST WANT TO JOIN WITH
CENTER EGGMAN ON ON HER
CONCERNS AND THE LIKE LOOK I
THINK THE AMENDMENTS FROM WHAT
I CAN DETERMINE THAT HELP
DRAMATICALLY. BUT I JUST
HISTORICALLY WANT TO PUT THIS
IN CONTEXT CENTER MAKE DURING
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN CHAIR OF
PROBATION IS BIG AND- INDUCES
BILL BACK IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
TO CREATE CCA'S. AND WE ARE DO
WE ARE TRYING TO DEVELOP IN A
VERY. APPROPRIATE MANNER THIS
BALANCE WHERE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WE DEAL WITH THE
GHGS AND GREEN ENERGY IS AS
BEST AS WE CAN. BUT I'M SO.
SCARRED BY THE ENERGY CRISIS
THAT I AM SCARED. BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW IF HE'S ALIVE THESE
FOLKS HAVE- BALANCE SHEETS IT'S
EASY FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS TO SAY AND LIST ON
HERE WE WANTED OF COURSE. BUT
THERE ARE PUTTING UP THEIR FULL
FAITH AND CREDIT OF THEIR
CITIES TO DO SO. THEY'RE
THEY'RE CHERRY PICKING IN AND
IT CREATES THIS CHALLENGE NOW
THE P. YOU SEE HAS BEEN VERY
SLOW AND DRAGGING ITS FEET. IN
THIS PROCESS AND I UNDERSTAND
THE FRUSTRATION. BUT WHEN
YOU'RE DEALING WITH THIS WHOLE
ISSUE OF- YOU KNOW AND I
REMEMBER COMING HERE IF YOU
LOOK AT THE RELATED BILLS ARE
HERTZBERG BILLS HAVE BEEN
DEALING IN THE SYRIAN THE
DETAIL FOR A LONG TIME HIS
POWERS CHARGING DIFFERENCE
ADJUSTMENT. TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT POLAR WE DO THE BILL AND
PRIVATE THE PROVIDERS OF LAST
RESORT. THE ONE THING WE CAN'T
HAVE HAPPEN. IS ANOTHER ENERGY
CRISIS WE SAW THE TEMPERATURES
GO UP TO A HUNDRED THIRTY
DEGREES. LAST YEAR WE KNOW THAT
IMPACTS A LOT OF RENEWABLES
BOTH BATTERIES AND SOLAR. WE
EXPECT IT TO HAPPEN AGAIN THIS
YEAR IN THE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
I'VE GOT TWO BILLS HERE TODAY.
DEALING WITH THIS TRYING TO.
ADJUST FOR LONGER TERM THINKING
SO I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
TODAY. BUT I'M JUST NERVOUS
ABOUT THIS LARGER ISSUE. AND
CONCERNED THAT THIS IS LIKE A
IT REMINDS ME OF NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR WHEN WE WENT OUT.
DEREGULATE EVERYTHING EVERYBODY
WAS HAPPY ABOUT IT AND THEN ALL
OF A SUDDEN THE WORLD WENT
UPSIDE DOWN. I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH
BOOTS BELTS AND SUSPENDERS AND
ALL THIS STUFF. AND RESOURCE
ADEQUACY WHEN I INTERVIEWED
WHEN I WAS A RULES COMMITTEE.
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT AT AT
THE CALAIS SO. YOU KNOW HE WAS
SAYING THE PROBLEM LAST YEAR'S
WE DID HAVE A- A ROBUST ENOUGH
RESOURCE ADEQUACY. SO ALL OF
THIS STUFF RESOURCE ADEQUACY
POLAR PROVIDERS OF LAST RESORT
ALL OF THESE ISSUES. ARE PART
OF THIS LARGER DYNAMIC I SEE
THIS IS. AN EFFORT TO. TO PUSH
THE- PC A LITTLE BIT OR MAYBE
AS WAS SUGGESTED THERE WERE
SOME THAT WEREN'T AS HAPPY WITH
THAT. MISS SUPPORT THIS TONIGHT
I HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE IN
THE- THE AUTHOR OF THIS AND I
BELIEVE THAT THE AMENDMENTS
WENT PRETTY FAR IN HELPING.
THIS MEASURE ALONG I JUST HAVE
A CHANCE. TO ANALYZE THEM SO.
MARTIN BUT I WANT TO THAT. ON
WITH MY WRIST TO MY VOTER COMES
FOR EXAMPLE. THANK YOU CENTER
BACKERS AT YOUR MAKE UP. THANK
YOU I JUST IF YOU WANT TO ECHO
I THINK THESE ARE COMPLEX
ISSUES AND IT'S NICE TO SEE
CPUC FROM STARTING TO. TO MOVE
BUT I DO. WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR I AGREE THAT- THE
SUPPORTING THE CUSTOMERS ARE
PAYING FOR THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
THE COSTS OF LEGACY RESOURCES
AND THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THEY
GET THEIR SHARE THE BENEFITS AS
WELL SO I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR. BRINGING THIS FOR.
SENATOR BRADFORD THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I TO REMAIN ON
A NOTE IN A NOTE OF CAUTION
HERE- I KNOW OUR MAJORITY
LEADER LIVE DIRECTLY THROUGH
THE ENERGY CRISIS AS SPEAKER OF
THE ASSEMBLY BUT I DID SO AS AN
EMPLOYEE OF A MAJOR UTILITY AND
WE HAVE TO BE MINDFUL THAT. YES
WE ALL ABOUT CHOICE BUT. I'M
JUST CONCERNED CCA'S AS THE
MAJORITY LEADER STATED THERE'S
NO BALANCE SHEET HERE THERE'S
NO EMPLOYEES THEY'RE STILL
DEPENDENT ON THE SAME UTILITIES
THAT THEY SAY THEY WANT TO
BREAK AWAY FROM FOR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE BILLING
FOR THE METER READING ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT ISSUE SHE WILL
NEVER DO. AND THERE'S NO
GREATER POOL OF RENEWABLE OR
CLEAN ENERGY THAT'S AVAILABLE
TO THEM THAT IT'S AVAILABLE TO
DIAL USER APPEAL USE IT'S THE
SAME PART OF RENEWABLE ENERGY
NO GREATER SOURCE FILLED TO
CONTINUE TO SAY THAT. THEIR
CLEANER AND BETTER IT'S JUST A
FALLACY TO IT'S A IT'S A
POSSIBILITY- AND WE THROUGH
LEGISLATION OVER THE LAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS HAVE PUSH
UTILITIES TO THE POINT OF LONG
TERM CONTRACTS OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY AND NOW WE'RE LETTING
ALL THEIR CUSTOMERS MIGRATE
AWAY. AND WE SAY IT'S COMMUNITY
CHOICE BUT REALLY IT'S NOT IT'S
COMMUNITY FORCE BECAUSE IT
FORCED UPON THEM BY CITIES
ABOUT ELECTED LEADERS WHO ARE
MAKING DECISION NOT INDIVIDUAL
RATEPAYERS BECAUSE IF YOU TALK
TO THE INNER INDIVIDUAL REPAIR
THEY DON'T KNOW THEY'RE PART OF
A C. C. A. VERSUS I OWE YOU HE
STILL GET THEIR BILL FROM.
THEIR REGULAR. FIVE INCUMBENT.
UTILITIES STILL. I WISH YOU
WEREN'T. COMMUNITY CHOICE. IF
IT WORK IT WOULD BE. IN PURSES
OPT OUT. I'VE SAID IN A TALKED
TO ROOMS OF. ELECTED OFFICIALS
OVER LAST TWO YEARS MANY OF
WHOM WERE PART OF CCA'S AND A
NEW. REALLY NOTHING ABOUT THE
MECHANICS OF EACH YEAR I'VE
TALKED TO HUNDREDS OF CUSTOMERS
WHO LIVE IN DISTRICTS THAT ARE
C. CA AND THEY WEREN'T THE
LEAST BIT AWARE THAT THEY WERE
PART OF A CCA BECAUSE AGAIN.
THE COMMUNITY TO MAKE THE
CHOICE ELECTED OFFICIALS MAKE
THEIR CHOICE FOR THEM. AND I
THINK IT WOULD BUT ANYWAY. I'M
GONNA SUPPORTED TODAY BUT AGAIN
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE HERE IT'S SOUND SIMPLE.
YOU KNOW AND WANNA. WHAT THE
WHAT BACK THE PEACE BUT YOU WE
REALLY HAVE TO BE MINDFUL
BECAUSE- WHAT WE HAVE HERE THE
DAY IS A RECIPE FOR WHAT WE
SAW. AND THE ENERGY CRISIS IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE TWO HI I'M
THIS FOR THAT SO. I SAID I
WOULD DESCRIBE IT ACROSS. THANK
YOU. CENTER BRADFORD ANYBODY
ELSE LAST CHANCE BEFORE
RETURNING BACK TO. CENTER
PORTANTINO FOR CLOSING
ARGUMENTS ARE ADDRESSING THE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU- MISTER CHAIR OR VICE
CHAIR- I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
TODAY- AND I APPRECIATE THEIR
THEIR GUARD TO- YOU KNOW. THERE
IS AN EXISTING TREND. AND WE
NEED TO BE AHEAD OF THAT TREND
WE SHOULDN'T RE REACTING TO IT
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
DO HERE AND- I WILL TAKE
COMMENTS TO HEART AND CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I WILL.
THANK YOU WOOD THE CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SB SIX TALL BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO DO PASSED AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. WESSEL DOLLY.
BAKER HI BAKER I FORGES.
BRADFORD. DODD I DON I EGGMAN
HI EGGMAN I. THE DALLAS FIVE
GONZALEZ I. HELLO. HERTZBERG HI
HERTZBERG HI MCGUIRE. MAN I IN
HI RUBIO I. RUBIO I. THERMIDOR.
A RECORD BRADFORD AYE BRADFORD
HI STERN. SURE THERE'S A AS-
EIGHT WILL LEAVE AT ALL OPEN
FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON SIR. UP
NEXT WE WILL TAKE ITEM SB. SIX
SEVENTEEN. SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR OUR
COLLEAGUES- I'M AT THE NUMBERS
ANY SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTEEN.
I WANT TO THANK THE- CHAIRMAN
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR- FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL
AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- I ALSO
USES ONE NOTES- THAT- ID-
MISTER WHITE FOR MY B. W. TO
SUBMIT A LETTER WITHDRAWING
IDW'S OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
AND SO I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE WORKED. CLOSELY WITH IBEW TO
RESOLVE THEIR ISSUES AND MADE
AMENDMENTS INCOMING FINANCE
OTHER CAUSE THE REMOVAL OF THAT
OUR POSITIONS I WANT TO THANK
IPW FOR WORKING WITH US. I'M
CALLING THIS PROCESS SIX
SEVENTEEN REQUIRES-
JURISDICTIONS OF A CERTAIN SIZE
TO IMPLEMENT AUTOMATED ONLINE
SOLAR PERMITTING FOR SIMPLE
RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP SOLAR AND
SOLAR PLUS STORAGE SYSTEMS THIS
IS. ABOUT REALLY SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES AND IT'S ABOUT SIMPLE
SYSTEMS NOT LARGE COMPLICATED
SYSTEMS FURTHER THE BILL
DIRECTS- THE ENERGY COMMISSION
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND GRANTS TO JURISDICTIONS FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AUTOMATED
ONLINE PERMITTING SYSTEMS AS
DESCRIBED IN THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH IS- A SOLAR
PERMITTING GUIDEBOOK BOTTOM ITS
SOLAR PERMITTING IS ONE OF THE
MAIN METHODS FOR AVOIDING
UNNECESSARY DELAYS. SAVING
FINANCIAL AND STAFF RESOURCES
AND INCREASING THROUGHPUT OF
PERMITS CURRENTLY SOLAR
PERMITTING PROCESSES ARE OFTEN
NOT ALWAYS BUT OFTEN
INEFFICIENT- CAN RESULT CAN
INCREASE OFF COSTS BY UPWARDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
APPLICANTS A DROP AL PRIOR TO
INSTALLATION AND DETER
POTENTIAL CUSTOMERS FROM
ENGAGING IN A DRAWN OUT PROCESS
TOGETHER RESIDENTIAL SOLAR
SYSTEM. AUTOMATED ONLINE SOLAR
PERMITTING ALLOWS FOR A
SIMPLIFIED AND FAR MORE
EFFICIENT SOLUTION BY ALLOWING
APPLICANTS TO APPLY AND
IMMEDIATELY DETERMINE IF THE
PROPOSED. SYSTEM IS CODE
COMPLIANT. KERN ALL PER SYSTEM
ARE KEY OF FOR HANDLING. TIMES
MORE PERMITS THAN TYPICAL
METHODS SAN JOSE RECENTLY
IMPLEMENTED AN AUTOMATED SYSTEM
SALAS 6100% INCREASE IN
PERMITS. THIS INCREASED VOLUME
OF PERMITS IS NOT A BURDEN ON
BUILDING DEPARTMENT STAFF. AS
pPERMITS SO OFTEN THE LARGEST
PORTION OF PERMITS BEING DEALT
WITH THE MATTER IS
AUTOMATICALLY. FURTHER
DEPARTMENTS WILL COLLECT FEES
ARE FOR ME TO PERMITS OR NOT
REDUCING THE FEES THAT THEY
COLLECT GENERATING
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE REVENUE DUE
TO THE UP TICK IN CASELOADS. TO
SISTER INSTRUCTIONS ARE WHICH
MAY STRUGGLE IMPLEMENTING SUCH
A SYSTEM SB SIX SEVENTEEN
CREATES A PROGRAM AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
AND FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE-
ALTHOUGH SB SIX SEVENTEEN DOES
NOT MANDATE A SPECIFIC
TECHNOLOGY OR SYSTEM. THE
BILL'S INTENT IS DIRECTLY TIED
TO SOLAR OP A RECENTLY
DEVELOPED SOFTWARE FROM THE-
NATIONAL RENEWABLE ENERGY LAB
AND ARIELLE WHICH IS- PART OF
THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY.
WHICH WAS CREATED ALONGSIDE
BUILDING DEPARTMENT SAFETY
EXPERTS SOLAR INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS AND OTHERS. SOLAR
APP IS FREE AND OPEN SOURCE AND
CAN BE EASILY. IMPLEMENTED BY
ANY JURISDICTION. BUILDING THE
WILL BE ABLE TO ON BOARD THIS
WITH IN I FOR. AND EVEN MERGE
THE PROGRAM WITH OTHER COMMONLY
UTILIZED GOVERNMENT SOFTWARE
FURTHERMORE THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY AND ARIELLE WE'RE
COMMITTED TO THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF SOLAR UP. AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS HAS BEEN
APPROPRIATED TO SUPPORT THE
SOFTWARE OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS. ON SOLAR OUT
SPECIFICATIONS ARE BASED ON
MODEL BUILDING AN ELECTRICAL
FIRE CODES AND ACROSS REFERENCE
WITH THE LEADING PERMITTING
GUIDEBOOKS IN CALIFORNIA. OVER
FIFTY JURISDICTIONS ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF EVALUATING THE
SOFTWARE AND CITIES SUCH AS
MODESTO MENIFEE OCEANSIDE IN
PLEASANT HILL. ARE ALL IN
VARIOUS STAGES OF ADOPTION NONE
OF WHOM HAVE INDICATED ANY
MAJOR ISSUES. I'M MORE THAN
ANYTHING SB SIX SEVENTEEN AS A
CLIMATE BILL WHETHER
JURISDICTION UTILIZES SOLAR OP
OR CREATE THEIR OWN AUTOMATED
PERMITTING SYSTEM BOTH WILL
HELP BUILD MORE SOLAR. A COLD
CALIFORNIA DESPERATELY NEEDS TO
ACHIEVE TO ACCOMPLISH AND TO
MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS. ARE
CURRENTLY ONLY 10% OF REPAIRS
OF SOLAR ENERGY THAT NUMBER
NEEDS TO TRIPLE IN THE NEXT
DECADE WE EXPECT. TO MEET OUR
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS. I CALLING I
RESPECT ASK FOR YOUR HYDRO.
WITH ME TODAY TESTIFY AREN'T
EXCEPT SUCH PAPA SPUR. AND JEFF
CO- WITH RENEWABLE. POLICY
BECAUSE RENEWABLE ENERGY POLICY
MARKET ANALYST- AT THE US
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY'S NATIONAL
RENEWABLE ENERGY LABORATORY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR WIENER
WIENER SO- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE- WOULD BE JEFF OR NICK I
DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE'S GOING
FIRST TO PLEASE YOUR DEVICES
THOSE WHO ARE ONLINE SO THAT WE
DON'T GET THE FEEDBACK AND YOU
MAY START. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CHAD BECAUSE- NICK TO
SEPARATES- AND- I WANT TO THANK
YOU AND COMMITTEE STOPPED- WHAT
THE BUSSER PRODUCTIVELY ON THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS BIG JUST
SEPARATE CLIMB THE CHIEF OF
POLICY SPA- SPOKE- IS A- A
HUNDRED YEAR OLD THINK TANK
THAT WORKS ON THE STATE
ABILITY. GOOD GOVERNMENT
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE SPYRUS
COSPONSORING SB SIX SEVENTEEN
WITH ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE WE HAVE MORE WORK TO DO
TO ADDRESS THE CIMATE CRISIS.
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION JOINTLY WITH THE PC
AND CALL THE ESTIMATE THE
CALIFORNIA WILL BE TO TRIPLE
THE AMOUNT OF SO LET. ME TELL
100% CLEAN ELECTRICITY GOALS.
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
ACCELERATE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
SOLAR IN OUR STATE IS TO MAKE
IT QUICKER AND CHEAPER TO
INSTALL CYNICAL RESIDENTIAL
ROOFTOP SOLAR AND SOLAR PLUS
STORAGE SYSTEMS. THERE IS A
LONG WAY TO GO. DESPITE COST
LEGISLATIVE REFORMS THE SOFT
COSTS IN THE TYPICAL
RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP SOLAR
SYSTEM. BY RENTAL UNIT DIRECTLY
ASSOCIATED WITH PERMITTING CAN
BE SEVERAL THOUSAND DOLLARS.
FOR TYPICAL RESIDENTIAL SYSTEM.
MY OF THIS COST IS GIVEN BY THE
PRO. TIME OF HOW LONG IT TO GET
A- WHICH IS STILL STOP HIGH
OVER THE PA DECADE. THE
SOLUTION IS TO BUILD ON THE
SUCCESS OF JURISDICTIONS LIKE
SAN JOSE LOS ANGELES SAN LUIS
OBISPO AND MANY OTHERS. WHO TO
MAKE IT A PUBLIC PICK PRINCIPLE
RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP SOLAR AND
SOLAR PLUS STORAGE SYSTEMS.
APPROVED MORE PUNDITS HAVE
DEVOTED MORE KANYE BE REVENUE I
HAVE BEEN SCHOOLS MUCH MORE
SODA. THAT'S WHAT SB SIX AND
THIS. ACCESS DOES IT WORK LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. I'M I'LL BOTHER
SAID SIZE ORTOM STYLE APARTMENT.
TO ACCELERATE ADOPTION OF
AUTOMATED PROVIDING THE MEDICAL
RECORDS AND IMAGING TO THAT
YOU'RE A LOT TIME. SO THE OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK- AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
IPOD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NOW
COOK JEFF COOK IS ON THE LINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS THIS IS
JEFF COOK RENEWABLE ENERGY
POLICY AND MARKET ANALYST HERE
AT THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY. ENERGY NATIONAL
RENEWABLE ENERGY LABORATORY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS EN ROUTE SO
I'M THE PROJECT LEAD FOR SOLAR
AT THE INSTANT ONLINE
PERMITTING. OR BROKEN PLATE
RESIDENTIAL ROOFTOP SOLAR
SYSTEMS. I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE A
FEW WORDS ON THE DEVELOPMENT
AND OPERATION OF THE SOFTWARE.
PRODUCT SPECTACULAR AFTER
REDUCE ROOFTOP SOLAR PERMITTING
TIMELINE. POTENTIALLY LOWERING
THE COST OF FULLER AND LEADING
TO INCREASED ADOPTION. OR APPLE
CHOIRS THAT LIGHTEN CONTRACTORS
INPUT THE DESIGN
SPECIFICATIONS. THEN UPLOAD
RELATED DATA SHEETS AND
DOCUMENTS. THE TOP MORE THAN
PERFORM CODE COMPLIANCE CHECK
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
PROPOSED SYSTEM. ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRICAL AND
BUILDING CODES. IF THE LAB
VERIFIED COMPLAINT. FORM ISSUE
THE PERMIT AUTOMATICALLY. IF
NOT THE CONTRACTORS INSTANTLY
NOTIFIED IF CO DEFICIENCIES.
ALLOWING FOR IMMEDIATE
REVISION. THE TOOL IS OFFERED
AT NO COST TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND WAS DEVELOPED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL CODE COUNCIL.
WHICH DEVELOPED THE CODE BEHIND
THE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTIAL AND
BUILDING CODE. AND THE NATIONAL
FIRE PROTECTION ASSOCIATION
WHICH DEVELOPED THE CODE BEHIND
THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRICAL CODE.
AND WILL ALSO BUILD UPON THEIR
APARTMENT BEEN CREATED IN THE
AFTER MENTIONED SOLAR
PERMITTING GUY BACK. CREATED BY
THE CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
TO ENSURE OF COURSE WITH THE
FULLER APP MATCHES VERIFIED
THAT PRACTICES IN THE FIELD.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ABOUT THE
PRODUCT THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH THE STATE ON TIME
PRITCHETT THAT VERY MUCH DO WE
HAVE ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY.
LIKE SPEAKING OPPOSITION ANYONE.
ABOUT A ONE TWELVE TO WE HAVE A
THERE NO WAY AND ONE TWELVE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LAW. NOW
THIS IS FIRST SIX ONCE.
MODERATE PLEASE SPEAK AND SO OF
US SIX SEVEN. THANK YOU LADIES
AND IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
SUPPORT OF S. SIX ONE SEVEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HI THIS IS LAUREN
CALLING ON BEHALF OF YOUR CLUB
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. NEXT TO OPEN MY NUMBER
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU CAN DOWN IN
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. ANNEX TO OPEN
MY NUMBER ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SILVIO FERRARI ON
BEHALF OF SUNPOWER CORPORATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PICKER. NEXT TO OPEN MY
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THAT MEASURE
MEMBERS VINCENT WERE MUCH OF
WHAT THE CONTACT CENTRE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. NEXT TO OPEN MY
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. CAPTION INDICATOR
CROWDY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. NEXT TO OPEN MY
NUMBER ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. PARDONS FOR
TECHNOLOGIES IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT BAKER. LINE ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT ON THE G. CARE MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE TREAT ON BEHALF OF
TECH THE BOARD. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. LINE EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MISTER
CHAMBERS DELANEY HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION AND THE
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. ONE ONE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARK RODRIGUEZ
THE SUN RUN IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB SIX ONE SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. LINE ONE
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. ONE SEVENTY FEAR LINE IS
OPEN. HEY THIS IS KELLY ALLING
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE DAIRY
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. A LINE ONE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADAM GENSERIC ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
ONE SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. ONE ONE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. WE
WILL CLOSE ON COULD RECOLLECT
ENERGY IN SUPPORT. THAT COULD
MAKE SPEAKER. ONE SIXTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. KIM
LLOYD PRESIDENT TOM DALY.
STRONG SUPPORT SENATE BILL SIX
ONE SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. LINE ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU PAIR WITH
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. ONE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON AT THE
BALL SANSHIN THE COASTAL
INTERNET ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE COLOR ACCENT NOT. THANK YOU
NEXT BECAUSE. LINE ONE SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS RACHEL WILLIAMS I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF EACH YEAR
FULLER ONLINE IN STRONG SUPPORT
WE ARE ALL IN STRONG SUPPORTER
OF SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CAN EXPECT. LINE
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HELLO CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAD
MURRAY WITHOUT CHECKS ALL OUR
RANCH RECORD OVER AND ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOLAR AND STORAGE. ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. I CAN EXPECT. ONE
ONE TWO YEAR LINE IS NOW. I AM
CURRENTLY ON A- FOR. THANK YOU
NEXT WEEK. BEFORE WE OPEN UP
OUR LAST LINE ONE SEVENTY NINE
AS A REMINDER TO ANYONE WHO'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX ONE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE ONE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. YEAH CAN I AFTERNOON
RESPECT SAN DIEGO. FULL SUPPORT
THE- BILL SIX ONE SEVEN. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. LINE ONE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
ANNOUNCER CLIMATE ACTION IN
SUPPORT OF SB CLINTON. THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. ONE ONE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SINCE
THEN THEY'VE IT MCCORD- IN. IN
EL READER AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT BECAUSE- ONE ONE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. DID THAT
HAPPEN WITH ALL THE LEAKS
BULLER IN STRONG SUPPORT LOS
ANGELES. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
THANK YOU. AND AT THE TIME I
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NOW WILL MEET MOVED
TO THE OPPOSITION SIDE WE HAVE
A SPEAKER- THAT'S PART OF AN
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION ON IN
OPPOSITION RON TACKY GUCCI.
WITH THE- HE'S A BUILDING
OFFICIAL FOR THE CITY BURBANK-
SHE ON THE PHONE MISTER CAR
TAKING WHICH IS BIG WHEN YOU'RE
READY- YES AUDIBLE LAWCENTER
CHAIRMAN WESSEL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS RON TALKING TO CHANGE
ON THE CHIEF BUILDING OFFICIAL
FOR THE CITY BURBANK BUT TODAY.
I'M REPRESENTING THE
ORGANIZATION KNOWN AS
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS
OR CALVET. I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING CENTER WINNER TO STOP
WITH THE WORK ON SB SIX
SEVENTEEN. CALVO HAS BEEN
HEAVILY ENGAGED IN
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS BILL.
INTRODUCTION WHAT WE HAVE
VOICED OUR CONCERNS AND DROPPED
IT AMENDMENTS. HOWEVER WE HAVE
YET TO SEE ANY ACTIONS ARE
PROPOSALS IN THERE FOR CAPITAL
CONTINUES TO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS BILL. IN ITS CURRENT
FORM. AGAIN WE WANT TO THANK
CENTER WIENER AND SPONSORS FOR
THEIR DIALOGUE. KALBA STILL
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB SIX
SEVENTEEN. I WOULD HOPE IN A
LONG TIME ADVOCATE OF
LEGISLATION THAT FURTHERS THE
STATE'S GOALS OR MARTIN BY
MENTAL SUSTAINABILITY AND
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION.
TOGETHER WITH OUR STATE
LEGISLATORS WE FEEL THAT THESE
GOALS CAN BE ACHIEVED IN A
MANNER THAT PROVIDE FULL
FEASIBILITY. AND SAFETY THAT
ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ABILITY TO COMPLY. SENATE FOR
SUCH POLICIES WITH US AUTO
FOCUS ON THESE TWO CENTRAL
CONCERNS FIRST OUR CONCERN WITH
THE MANDATED USE OF AUTOMATED
PROVIDING SOFTWARE. CAL MEMBERS
WELCOME TECHNOLOGY THAT
PROMOTES EFFICIENCY AND
STIMULATE THE ECONOMY WHEN
THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE TESTED
INVENTED BUT THAT IT BEFORE
IT'S MANDATED USE. COUPLE HAS
WORKED WITH THE SOFTWARE
DEVELOPERS ARE STILL AROUND.
BUT THEY HAVE INFORMED US THAT
THEIR TECHNOLOGY IS NOT READY
FOR FULL DEPLOYMENT OF ALL
SYSTEMS. THE ASSOCIATED OF
SYSTEMS LIKE. TYPES OF ROLES.
JUST POINT LEADS CALVET BELIEVE
THAT WE'RE PUTTING DEEPER. CART
THE HORSE. HI MANDY ADAM KURMA
PUT OUT PROPERTY. OR DO OF
BUILDING IT'S OF PUBLIC SAFETY
IN THE BUILDING. WITH WE
BELIEVE THAT A PILOT PROJECT
WOULD BE BETTER SUITED BEFORE
MOVING TO A LOCAL MANDATE.
SECOND OF OUR CONCERN OF THE
BILL'S IMPACT ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND POTENTIAL IMPACT OF
RESIDENTIAL HOMEOWNERS GIVEN
RAPID CHANGE IN TECHNOLOGY AND
PRODUCTS OF SOLAR PHOTOVOLTAIC.
IN ENERGY STORAGE SYSTEMS.
BUILDING OFFICIALS HAVE
CONCERNS FOR SAFE COMPLIANT
INSTALLATIONS. OR INCOME
INCORRECT CONFIGURATIONS COULD
RESULT IN UNSAFE SYSTEMS. AN
ADDITIONAL COST OF THE
HOMEOWNER. FURTHER THE BILL'S
ALLOWANCE OF EXPORT WAS STORED
ENERGY COULD HAVE CONSEQUENCES
TO THE UTILITY GRID. AND GRID
RELIABILITY. IN CLOSING I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT
CANNIBALS CONTINUE CONCERNS.
WITH SB SIX SEVENTEEN. COUPLE
LOOKS FORWARD TO MORE
PRODUCTIVE DIALOGUE TO CHEAT
THE UNDERLYING GOALS OF THE
STILL. THE MORE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS ON HOW TO
SUCCESSFULLY ACHIEVE CLIMATE
CHANGE GOALS IN CALIFORNIA. IN
THE FACE AND ECONOMIC MANNER.
THANK YOU. AND WE RESPECTFULLY.
URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS- WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO- SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. OF S. B. SIX ONE
SEVEN ANYONE HERE IN THE
GALLERY WE SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIX ONE SEVEN. WHO WERE
TO- ROOM ONE TWELVE NOBODY IS
PRESENT ROOM ONE TWELVE. NOW
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX ONE SEVEN.
CERTAINLY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX ONE SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. OPEN MY NUMBER ONE EIGHT
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
YOUR TURN MEMBERS PROBABLY
ITALY'S SHOCK IN BEHALF OF THE
DEMAND ENERGY ECONOMY APOLOGIES
I'M ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. TO SIX
ONE SEVEN A QUICK PLEASE-
CALLED THE NEXT BIG FOR.
CERTAINLY WHY NUMBER ONE TWO
ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
CLOTURE NUMBERS THEY'RE TALKING
THE HAPPENED LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN OPPOSITION
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH AUTHORED SPONSORS
ON THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. NEXT TO OPEN
MY NUMBER ONE TWO THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS ERIN SCHNEIDER MAYOR SAID
MILLBRAE. JOINT THE CITY HASN'T
TAKEN AN OFFICIAL POSITION
HOWEVER WE HAVE CONCERNS FROM
OUR BUILDING DEPARTMENT ON
VIRTUAL INSPECTION AND HOW WELL
BUILT THE PROJECT WOULD BE WE
ARE A CITY THAT ALSO HAS MANY
PEOPLE THAT TAKE A PERMIT OUT
AND THEN BUILD SOMETHING ELSE
ENTIRELY WE ARE WORKING ON THAT
BUT PERMITTED INTEGRITY IS AN
ISSUE WE WANT TO SUPPORT IT.
BUT I THINK THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES IN TERMS OF HONESTY AND
PERMITTING THAT STILL NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED SO WE ARE NEUTRAL
AT THIS TIME NEUTRAL OR OPPOSED.
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF BILL SB SIX ONE SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS WANTED IN THERE- AT THIS
TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION- OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE COMMITTEE
NOW FOR COMMENTS ANYONE HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE WISH TO SPEAK ASK
QUESTIONS. OR MAKE A MOTION.
AND OF COURSE- THE AUTHOR I
JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY WHAT THE
AUTHOR THAT HE HAS. ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENTS CORRECT. AND SO
THE ONE WHICH INITIALLY- CENTER
EGGMAN- SHOOT- CENTER EGGMAN
THANK YOU CENTERMAN AGREEMENT
MAKES A MOTION- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS- IF
THERE'S NO FOR THE COMMENTS-
CLICK PLEASE CALL. THE ROLE
HONESTLY. SIX ONE SEVEN. SB SIX
ONE SEVEN BY SENATOR WIENER TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
WESSEL. WETZEL HI DOLLY. NOTE
TELLING THEM BAKER HI BAKER
FIVE LARGEST. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I. DODD I DON I EGGMAN
FIVE EGGMAN I GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I. HELLO I. GROW BY.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I MCGUIRE.
MAN OF MAN I. RUBIO YEAH. RUBIO
I. STERN. STERN I. ELEVEN A
STIR. OKAY ON THE DO WE HAVE
ANYONE MISSING ON THAT. ELEVEN
AS AND ONE NOW AND WE'RE- OKAY
HERE WE ARE MISSING A MEMBER
WITH US IN A MEMBER SO WE'LL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN- TO
ACCOMMODATE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
ONE OF OUR CONVERSATION. WILL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT BILL BY
CENTER GONZALEZ. AND THIS ITEM
FOR SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT BY
CENTER GONZALEZ. AS BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND BEFORE I BEGIN I'D
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS WHICH WILL
ADD CLARIFICATION AROUND SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS AND DIG SAFE RULES
FOR WHEN MY CAR TRENCHING.
MISTER CHERN NUMBERS- I'M HERE
TO PRESENT SB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE IS
A KEY COMPONENT TO CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE BY PROVIDING
CLARITY TO INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
DEPLOYMENT METHODS SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL HELP PROMOTE
THE DEPLOYMENT OF BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INTERNET
CONNECTIVITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS BY REQUIRING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ALLOW FIBER
CABLES TO BE INSTALLED
UNDERGROUND USING COST
EFFECTIVE TECHNIQUES INCLUDING
OPEN TRENCHING BORING.AND OF
COURSE MICHAEL CHANGING THIS
BILL WILL BE CREATED BEST
PRACTICES STANDARD FOR MICRO
CHANGING IN RELATION TO PUT TO
DEPLOYING BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT LOCAL
PLANNING AGENCIES MUST FOLLOW
WHEN AN ENTITY SIX TO THE PLAY
BROADBAND IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY CURRENTLY EVERY LOCAL
JURISDICTION IN CALIFORNIA HAS
A VERY DIFFERENT FIBER
INSULATION REQUIREMENTS WHICH
OFTEN THE MAJOR TIME DELAY IN
BROADBAND PROJECT APPROVAL AND
DEPLOYMENT AS WELL AS COST.
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE NOW THAT
BROADBAND IS SO ESSENTIAL TO
MANY CALIFORNIANS- THIS WILL
ALSO ADDRESS THE LACK OF
CONTINUITY BY CREATING A
STATEWIDE STANDARD FOR MICRO
TRENCHING AS A DEPLOYMENT
OPTION FOR BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY I HAVE DANCED
WISER TO DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS OF CROWN CASTLE AND
ERICA HOFFMAN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. ONE OF THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR BOTH YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE CONSULTS AGAIN FOR
HELPING US SERVE SO GREATLY
AFTER THIS PROCESS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IPHONE SB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
THANK YOU WE WILL- WE HAVE TWO
SPEAKERS- THREE MINUTES TOTAL-
SO- EACH SPEAKER WILL GET A
MINUTE AND A HALF NINETY
SECONDS IF THEY COULD PLEASE
CONFINE THOSE YOUR COMMENTS TO
NINETY SECONDS WE HAVE DAN.
SCHWEITZER FOLLOWED BY ERICA
HOFFMAN IS MR DAN SHORT.
SCHWEITZER ONLINE. I DO NOT SEE
HIM ON THE PHONE LINES THERE.
IS ERICA HOFFMAN ON THE LINE. I
DO NOT SEE HER ON THE PHONE
LINE AT HOME EITHER. IF EITHER
ON THE PHONE WITH A NEW
DEADLINE PLEASE PRESS ONE IN
THE ROLE WE CAN OPEN UP YOUR
LINE. THEN WE WILL MOVE- TWO
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. OF SB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE HERE ON THE FLOOR IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT. I DON'T SEE ANY HANDS TO
WE HAVE ANYBODY ROOM ONE TWELVE.
THEN WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES- MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT.
CERTAINLY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL SB THREE
SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME FOR BILL SB. THREE
SEVEN EIGHT. OPEN MY NUMBER
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. PLEASE SHARE MEMBERS
MICHAEL GUNNING HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT BECAUSE. MY NUMBER
ONE EIGHT NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JOHNSON
HIGHER FROM THE BUILT ON BUT WE
ARE SHOULD GROUP AND WE'RE
PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. WHY
NUMBER SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IT REMINDED ME THAT WERE
UNABLE TO HEAR YOU. AND WITH NO
RESPONSE WILL HOLD THE LINE AS
A REMINDER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF BILL SB THREE SEVEN
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND I'VE NO ONE ELSE%
AT THE PORT. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
GO BACK TO I BELIEVE THEN
SCHWEITZER AND ERICA HOFFMAN
ARE BACK ON THE LINE SO. IF
DENCH WATCHERS ARE YOU HAVE A
MINUTE AND A HALF. YES THANK
YOU GENERATE SOME COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAN TRIED
SURROUNDING DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR CROWN
CASTLE. WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR
SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT BECAUSE
ITWILL ALLOW BROADBAND
PROJECT. IN STATE TO BE BUILT
QUICKER WHILE THE SAME TIME
REDUCING CONSTRUCTION IMPACTS
IN COMMUNITIES- INSURANCE
INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICE OF MICRO
TRENCHING. IS ALLOWED BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO INSTALL HIGH
SPEED INTERNET FIBER. CABLES
UNDERGROUND MICHAEL TRENCHING
TECHNOLOGY CUT TO TWO INCH WIDE
BY APPROXIMATELY TWO COULD BE
TRANSLATE A FIVER UNDERGROUND
BOX I DON'T THINK IT'S THE BACK
FEELING. AND FEELING ENTIRE
PROCESS TAKES HOURS INSTEAD OF
DAYS AND CARS CAN DRIVE ON THE
ROAD ON THE SAME DAY. MY
CONTENTION THAT QUICKLY 60%
CHEAPER AND 80% QUICKER THAN
TRADITIONAL OPEN TRENCH ST
ACTIVATIONS WHICH CURRENT LAN
CLOSURES AND NEGATIVELY IMPACTS
NEIGHBORHOODS. THE TECHNOLOGY
IS BEING USED IN CITIES AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND IT'S BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY DEPLOYED LOS
ANGELES WERE OVER FORTY MILES
OF FIBER HAPPENS. ALL THE
RESPONSE. THE BILL IS NECESSARY
TO MANY CHURCH. ARE CONTINUAL
WITH YOUR TECH. THAT CITY STAFF
ARE USED TO THE OLDER DISRUPT
METHOD OF OPEN. MCCARTY
COMPLIES WITH ALL. SAFETY RULES
AND GOES FURTHER BY USING
GROUND PENETRATING RADAR PRIOR
TO INSTALLATION. QUICKER
INSTALLATION OF FIBER MEAN
COMMUNITIES AROUND THE STATE
AND IT CONNECTED TO HIGH SPEED
FIBER OR HIGH SPEED INTERNET IN
DAYS INSTEAD OF MONTHS. THIS
WILL COMPLEMENT THE STATE LEVEL
TO PROVIDE MORE FUNDING FOR
BROADBAND BY ENSURING THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE DOLLARS TO
MAXIMIZE. AND BENEFIT RESIDENTS
THAT'S QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE WE
COMMEND SENATOR DUMBBELLS FOR
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND
AFTER I THOUGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK. YOU KNOW WILL MOVE
TO ERICA HOFFMAN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ERICA HOW AND I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION. IS COMMITTED TO
BROADBAND EXPANSION IN
CALIFORNIA TO CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE AND IMPROVE THE LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL STUDENTS.
LAST YEAR HAS SHOWN THAT NOW
MORE THAN EVER THE STATE NEEDS
TO DO ALL IT CAN. TO ENSURE
THAT OUR SCHOOLS STUDENTS I
CONNECTED TO HIGH SPEED
INTERNET. WE SUPPORT SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT BECAUSE IT WILL
ALLOW FOR QUICKER INSTALLATION
OF FIBER FOR HIGH SPEED
INTERNET PROJECTS. THROUGH THE
USE OF MICROTONES AND- CFTA
STRONGLY SUPPORT STREAMLINING
OUR PROCESSES TO HELP
ACCELERATE THE DEPLOYMENT OF
BROADBAND. THIS BILL WILL HELP
EXPEDITE BROADBAND ACCESS TO
COMMUNITIES IN NEED. OF HELP
ADDRESS LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
AND THE HOMEWORK GAP FOR
STUDENTS- DRIVER ON THAT.
MEASURE AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
MOVE. THE LEAD SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE SEVEN
EIGHT MY UNDERSTANDING IS BOTH.
ARE HERE IN THE GALLERY
BEGINNING WITH BRAIN IT'S
ENOUGH SEEN- SHE'S A FORMER
MAYOR OF NEVADA CITY. WELCOME.
HELLO THANK YOU. WE'VE BEEN LED
TO BELIEVE MICRO TRENCHING IS
BEST PRACTICES LOOKING SB THREE
SEVEN EIGHT TO THE EYES OF
FORMER TWO TIME MAYOR AND CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS ABOUT THE CITY
ALL I CAN SAY IS THIS BILL IS A
PANDORA'S BOX WE KNOW FOR A
FACT THIS BILL AND THAT THE
INTENDED MACRO MICRO TRENCHING
ISSUES DURING SUES WE ARE
GUARANTEED CITIES AND COUNTIES
ARE CALIFORNIA LOOK A LOT LIKE
LOUISVILLE KENTUCKY AND THE
FAILED GOOGLE FIBER OPTICS TO
BUCKLE. SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT
WILL LITERALLY SUPERSEDE A
LOCAL AUTHORITY AND ENGINEERING
BY FORCING CALIFORNIA CITIES
AND COUNTIES IN THE RESPECTIVE
STREETS WATER AND COMMUNICATION
SYSTEMS TO BE AT THE MERCY OF
AN ALREADY FELT EXPERIMENT LIKE
LOUISVILLE WE WILL BE LEFT WITH
THE AFTERMATH OF THEIR FAILED
FIBER BACKHAUL LINES WE BILLS
DISASTROUS GOOGLE FIBER OPTICS
MICRO TRENCHING PROJECT IS A
CLEAR HARBINGER FOR CALIFORNIA
GOOGLE'S PROBLEMS IN LOUISVILLE
STEM FROM ITS DECISION TO LAY
ITS CABLING JUST INCHES BELOW
THE ROAD SURFACE JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA SB THREE SEVEN IS
PROPOSING. A YEAR AGO GOOGLE
AGREED TO PAY THE BILL THREE
POINT EIGHTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN ORDER TO RESTORE
ROADS AND PUBLIC RIGHTS OF WAY
FOLLOWING THE GIANT TAX EXIT
FROM THE FIBER BUSINESS IN THE
CITY AND THE DEVASTATING MICRO
TRENCHING CHARGING WE BUILT A
MICRO TRENCHING TRIAL RAN INTO
PROBLEMS CAUSING THE PROCESS TO
COME INTO IT IT TO AN ABRUPT
HALT. TODAY LOUISVILLE'S
LEADERS HAVE BEEN LEFT HOLDING
THE BAG HAVING TO REPAIR THE
DAMAGE CAUSED BY THIS ILL FATED
MICRO TRENCHING SERVICE
UNDERSTAND UNFUNDED MANDATES
AND TOP DOWN DECISIONS NEVER
WORK FOR CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
COUNTIES- WHAT WILL WHO'S GOING
TO INSPECT THESE TRENCHES WHO'S
GOING TO ENSURE THAT THE
STANDARDS THAT WE ALL WANT TARA
BYE BYE WHO'S GOING TO ADD TO
IT WH'S GOING. TO CENTERS MY
NAME IS PAUL GAVIN FROM OUR
CALIFORNIA AND FIBER OPTIC IS
RIGHT UP OUR ALLEY WELL HERE'S
ONE THING YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND CROWN CASTLE IS NOT
A C. LIQUOR IN IRELAND THEY
HAVE NO ROLE HERE THEY ARE NOT
TO KERRY OR THEY DON'T GET
PREEMPTION. BOOK YOU JUST HEARD
ABOUT THE PROBLEMS NOW I HAVE
THE SOLUTIONS SP THREE SEVEN
EIGHT IS A PROMISING BILL WITH
AN ACHILLES HEEL THAT REQUIRES
A KEY AMENDMENT SENATOR
GONZALEZ CALL US WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THAT AMENDMENT HE
REQUIRES TO GIVE THE BILL TO
HELP THE LEGS THAT ARE NEEDED
TO ACTUALLY CLOSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. WHICH THIS BILL DOES
NOT. BUT WHAT HEALTHY AWAY IS
TO RESET. AND HONOR COULD. OVER
ALL ACTIVITY IN THE PUBLIC
RIGHTS OF WAY BECAUSE- ONE SIZE
DOES NOT FIT ALL IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA NOT ONE LICK.
HEALTHY LUDWIG REQUIRES THAT
THE PUBLIC BENEFIT TO BE
REALIZED FROM ANY. CONSTRUCTION
IN THE PUBLIC RIGHTS OF WAY.
THIS MEANS QUITE SIMPLY IF ANY
FIBER IS INSTALLED IN THE
RETAIL INDUSTRY. THEN THE
PUBLIC MUST HAVE A RIGHT TO
CONNECT TO ME DIRECTLY TO
BENEFIT FROM THAT FIBRE OPTIC
GOODNESS. DIRECTLY WITHOUT ANY
WIRELESS IN BETWEN THIS OPTION
MUST BE PRESENT FOR ACTUAL
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRALITY. CHILES
HERO IS REQUIRING. LOCAL
THIRTIES TO CHANGE THEIR- YES
OF. IT'S NOT A MINUTE FOR
RECORD THIS BILL I CAN'T THINK
A MORE ME FOR EVER WELL. THANK
YOU MCKENNA THANK YOU. OKAY
WE'LL GO TO US. AND OF THOROUGH.
ELSE LIKE TO ADD THEIR NAME ON
OPPOSITION. HERE IN THE GALLERY
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY. PLEASE
APPROACHED MY CAN ADD YOUR-
YOUR NAME YOUR POSITION. IN THE
ON THE BILL AND ANY AFFILIATION
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE. HELLO MY
NAME IS AMADA RYAN HURD AND I
OPPOSE SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT I'M
A TALK HOST STEWARDS AND I LIVE
IN SOUTH LAKE TAHOE CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME TO
THE CAPITAL. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. IN THE GALLERY. HI
MY NAME IS TRACY REINHARDT ON
FROM SOUTH LAKE TAHOE
CALIFORNIA AND I'M WITH TALL
WHOSE TWO WORDS AND I OPPOSE
THE SP THREE SEVEN EIGHT
SINCERELY IN MY HEART. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANYWAY OTHER
SPEAKERS HERE IN THE GALLERY.
WE'LL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
ANYONE ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ONE
IS PRESENT WE'LL GO TO THE
MODERATOR TO- Q. ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT THIS IS FOR
OPPOSITION OF. THREE SEVEN
EIGHT MODERATOR PLEASE TWO
SPEAKERS. CERTAINLY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO TO MY NUMBER ONE
NINE ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JEFF LERNER I
AM IN FAIRFAX AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT.
IT IS NOT RIGHT TO TAKE AWAY
LOCAL CONTROL FROM THE
COMMUNITY AND CITIZENS AND IT
IS A FIRE HAZARD. AND IT WOULD
NOT CLOSE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN
WE ASKED YOU TO LIMIT YOUR-
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION AND YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL. BUCKLER. PLEASE- I
MEAN I'M SORRY MODERATOR. KEEP
POSTED THE SPELL THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING THE NEXT SPEAKER.
MY NUMBER ONE EIGHT THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE EIGHT
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF
YOUR LINE IS MUTED WERE UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU. WILL BE NO LONGER
OPEN MY NUMBER ONE TWO SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE THOMAS FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA- CO FOUNDER OF
WIRELESS RADIATION EDUCATION
AND DEFENSE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT DOES NOT-
IT'S NOT SAFE IT TAKES AWAY
THANK YOU NEXT FROM A GROUP OF
MALES OKAY. WHY NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. YES THANK YOU THIS IS
CONNIE ANDERSON RESIDENT OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. AND THE
NUMBER OF WIRED WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE OF FIRE
AND SAFETY ISSUES THANK YOU
NEXT PICKER. LINE THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. JENNIFER
REPORTER WOULD SAY TECHNOLOGY
FOR SANTA ROSA PLEASE VOTE NO
ON THREE SEVEN EIGHT BECAUSE WE
MUST NOT PUT THE TELECOM
RATIONS IN CHARGE OF WHERE
THANK YOU NEXT BAKER. WHY ONE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS NOW. BUT IT
IS CALL REPORT. AND I BODES AS
SEVEN NOW YOU WILL BUT THE FIRE
CITED BY ALMOST EVERY AND THANK
YOU WEEK- NINE ONE NINE YEAR
LOW IS NOW ALL. HI THIS IS
WHAT'S WITH THE K. MINUTES THE
TWO SUCH CALLING TO REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION BUT ON THE AND STUFF
TODAY MARTIN THE AUTHOR HER
STAFF COMMITTEES IN SPITE FOR
WHAT WITH US THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. ONE ONE OH TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW A- MY NAME IS
MARISSA FOR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
AND I JUST OPPOSE IT B. THIRTY
SEVEN EIGHT THE IS A BAD BILL
FROM. THANK YOU A YOU THINKER.
ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
LONNIE GORDON AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF MALIBU
FOR SAFE TECH .ORG AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WEEK- LINE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
VICKY FEVERS EMF SAFETY NETWORK
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH MY
ORGANIZATION OPPOSES THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. LINE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
FOR THAT ONE SECOND OKAY WE CAN
THIS IS CHARLIE HOPE THE ICE
FROM BOSTON CA. I OPPOSE. THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY
NAME IS BRENDA MARTINEZ AND I'M
A BOARD MEMBER OF THE BOYLE
HEIGHTS NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL
THE CHAIR OF THE TRANSPORTATION
AND ENVIRONMENTAL COMMITTEE I
STRONGLY OPPOSES THE THREE
SEVEN AID THE STATE MUST
PROTECT LOCAL CONTROL OVER
PUBLIC RIGHT AWAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. MY
NUMBER FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. TIM HAHN PRIVATE
TUTOR IN SAN RAFAEL CALIFORNIA
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE SP THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PICKER. ONE ONE NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS LAURA COLBERT AND
TIME WITH WIRED BERKELEY AND
WITH THE NSAC NETWORK. AND I
OPPOSE ONE FOUR LOCAL CONTROL
PLEASE. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
WHY NUMBER NINETY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN HI MY NAME IS
ROBERT- JUST- WITH- NO MAS NO
MAS A RESIDUAL BURGER PRESSURE
FROM CORPORATIONS WHO ARE NOT
YOUR CONSIDERS CONSTITUENCIES
THEY'RE NOT CITIZENS I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. ONE
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MY NAME IS VICTORIA GOLD
REPRESENTING WATER FLOW SPRING
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CHASKA
AND ALSO ON THE CALIFORNIA
MISSISSIPPI COALITION.
ABSOLUTELY I DON'T KNOW
HONESTLY YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BAKER. ONE ONE NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS JODY NELSON ON THE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFE TECHNOLOGY WITH MEMBERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA WE STAND WITH
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
AND STRONGLY OPPOSE F. B. THREE
SEVEN EIGHT. NEXT PICKER. ONE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. NINE TWO THREE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME IS WELL IN
RELIGION I LIVE IN SEBASTOPOL
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE AT
THREE THREE SEVEN EIGHT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER.
NINE ONE OH FOR YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. THANK YOU SIR FOR ME
BACK IN ABOUT AN HOUR
COMMUNICATIONS ARE GOING UP
LIKE WHAT CAN THERE AND WE
STRONGLY. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK.
LINE HAD YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
KATHLEEN EGBERT FOR PEOPLE WHO
LOVE HAVE BEEN BY EXCESS BUT I
TO STRONG OPPOSE. THANK YOU
BECAUSE- NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THIS IS NANCY
MCCORD LASKY WITH NAPA COUNTY
ASSOCIATION FOR SAFE TECHNOLOGY
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO KEEP LOCAL
CONTROL OVER THE RIGHT TO PLAY.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
BAKER. BLIND SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
SIDNEY **** CALLING TO OPPOSE
SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT AND I
WOULD SAY TECH FOR SANTA ROSA
THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. NINE ONE
NINE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JEAN HERMAN
OF THE BEER IF YOU USE SOCIAL
JUSTICE COMMITTEE. WE URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO BECAUSE MICRO
TRENCHING IS DANGEROUS AND
BECAUSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
NEXT SPEAKER PLEASE. ONE ONE
NINE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HI MY NAME'S LANDRY PER
I'M WITH JOHN THE LAND THEIR
FEET AND BACK FAMILIES
ADVOCATING FOR CHEMICAL AND
TOXIC SPEAKING I STRONGLY THIS
BILL. THANK YOU BIG. A LINE ONE
NINE NINE YOUR LINE OF NOW OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS MARK MARK POLLARD-
SNOWMEN NEIGHBORS STATE TAX
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF CINEMA
WE'RE- FOR LOCAL CAN AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. THREE SEVEN
EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
BIG. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT THE NEURAL FOR SP THREE
SEVEN EIGHT. WE HAVE ONE PERSON
WITH AN OPERATOR FOR JUST ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. MY NUMBER ONE
EIGHT THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE EIGHT THREE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN WE CAN HEAR YOU. PLACE
YOUR LINE IS MUTED WHERE WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO QUITE HEAR YOU. THE
MOVE ONTO MY NUMBER TWO. OKAY
GO AHEAD. CAN YOU TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY WE'LL
MOVE ON TO LIKE TWO HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS PAMELA WHITMAN CRAFT FAMILY.
STRONGLY OPPOSING SB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT SHE- NEXT BIGGER.
ON THE THIRD ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE SEVEN EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL COME TO THE FLOOR NOW
SENATORS- ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS ON S. P. THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT. FOR A MOTION. WE HAVE A
MOTION. AND THE MOTION. IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
QUICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. S.
B. THREE SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SANDRA GONZALEZ THIRTY PLEASE-
CLERK WE HAVE A COMMENT BY A
MEMBER CENTER GROVE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I APOLOGIZE I'M
SORRY COULDN'T SEE ME I'M SURE
IT'S A REFLECTION ON THE GLASS.
AND QUESTION THE AUTHOR. IS ALL
OF THIS IS UNDERGROUND CORRECT.
MR CHAIRMAN YES IT IS UNDER THE
GROUND THERE WAS A COMMENT IN
THE- ME TOOS THAT SAYS THAT
THEY STOOD STRONGLY WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES I DIDN'T SEE
LIGA CITIES ON THE OPPOSITION
OUR LEAGUE OF CITIES AN
OPPOSITION THEY'RE NOT. THANK
YOU MA'AM. GREAT OKAY THANK YOU
WILL COME BACK TO- SIR GONZALEZ
DID YOU WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO OUR SPONSORS WHICH
INCLUDED A NUMBER OF OTHER
CITIES IN ASSOCIATIONS AND I
WANT TO THINK A LOT OF THE
MEMBERS OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
WORKING ON BROADBAND THIS IS
JUST ONE PIECE OF THE PUZZLE TO
EXPAND AND EXHAUST INTO-
CONTINUE- EXPANDING BROADBAND
ACCESS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SO
WITH THAT RESPECT THE ASPIRIN I
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION A CLERK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. S. B. THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SANDRA
GONZALEZ DO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. WESSEL HI.
WESEL EINE. DOLLY HI DOLLY HI
BECKER. BUY BAKER I. GORGEOUS
HIGH BOARD HIGH BRADFORD HI
RAPPER I DON HI DON I EIGHT MEN.
GONZALEZ FIVE DOLLARS HI GROSS
I GROSS HI HERTZBERG. RIGHT BY.
REQUIRE THE CHOIR HI. REQUIRE
FIVE MAN ALL MAN I. RUBIO I
RUBIO I STERN. SURE THAT'S
EIGHT TWELVE DAYS. OKAY ARE WE
MISSING ANY MEMBERS. TWO OKAY
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN- FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THIS BILL
AS WELL SO WE'LL MOVE NOT TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG BEGINNING THIS P.
FIVE TO NINE. SENATOR WELCOME.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. BUT THIS
MEASURE ITEM FIVE SP FIVE
TWENTY NINE IN THE SECOND MAJOR
ALL TRUNCATED SIX FORTY SIX-
TIED TOGETHER. AND IT
BASICALLY- FOLLOWS ON THE
COMMENTS I HAD WITH RESPECT TO.
CENTERPOINT TINO'S MEASURE. YOU
KNOW IT'S IN RESPONSE TO THE
ENERGY CRISIS IN TWO THOUSAND
ONE WE CREATED THIS CONCEPT OF
RESOURCE ADEQUACY THAT WE HAVE
BEEN DEALING WITH WITH THE PC.
INTO A SERIES OF BILLS OVER THE
LAST NUMBER OF YEARS AND AS
THERE'S BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN CUSTOMER CHOICE HAS
FORCED ELECTRIC RETAILER MARKET
PLACE TO CHANGE THAT A
REGULATORY SYSTEM MUST ADAPT.
THIS IS THAT AT AT AT TATIAN BY
ALLOWING FOR MULTI YEAR PROGRAM
WITH RESPECT TO RESOURCE
ADEQUACY AS I SAID THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALAIS SO WHEN I SPOKE
TO HIM WITH RESPECT TO THE
CHALLENGES LAST YEAR. TALKED
ABOUT THE NEED FOR DEEPER AND
MORE ROBUST RESOURCE ADEQUACY
ASKED FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
AND I DON'T SEE ANY SPEAKERS-
HERE ANYONE YOU WANT TO PRESENT
THE GALLERY IN ROOM TWELVE
ANYBODY PRESENT IN ONE ROOM
TWELVE. THERE ARE NO ORGANIZED-
SPEAKERS EITHER IN OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT. NO ONE IS THERE SO
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONES AND ASK
FOR SUPPORT PRESS FIVE TO NINE
MODERATOR COULD YOU HAVE A Q.
SUPPORT. FOR HIS P. FIVE TO
NINE. I'D BE GLAD TO LADIES
GENTLEMEN IF WISH TO BE OF THE
POOR OF BILL AT FIVE TO NINE
YOU MAY BE. ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO
SPEAK AT THE PORT OF SB FIVE
TWO NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE
IN SUPPORT. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION AGAIN I NOTICED
THERE WAS NO OPPOSITION
PRESIDENT AND ONE TWELVE OR THE
GALLERY. A MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF FIVE TO NINE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE TO NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE TWO NINE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE ZERO.
BUT I'VE NO ONE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU- ANIMAL MODERATOR
WILL COME TO THE COMMITTEE NOW
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY- ANY
QUESTIONS CONCERNS COMMENTS
RAISE YOUR HAND I SHOULD HIDE
SO I COULD SEE YOU IN CASE
THERE IS A THERE IS A- OKAY CAN
WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION. OF A
MOTION BY SENATOR MCGUIRE-
SEARCH FOR DID YOU WANNA MAKE A
CLOSING COMMENTS THANKS VERY
MUCH AS RELIABLE. THANK YOU UGH.
QUICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. S. B. FIVE
TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL I. WESSEL
HI DOLLY. HI DOLLY I BECKER.
BECKER HI FORGES FOR HIGH
BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI DONNA ALL
RIGHT DON I BIGMAN. CONSOLES.
GONZALEZ I. HELLO I GROUP I
HERTZBERG BY HERZBERG I REQUIRE
RIGHT REQUIRE FIVE MEN- MAN I.
RUBIO I'LL REVIEW I STERN. SURE
THAT'S TWELVE ACE. VERY WELL
HOLD THE ROLE OF THE TRAPS AND
MEMBERS CENTER HERTZBERG S. B.
SIX FOUR SIX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AGAIN ALONG
THE SAME LINES AS THE LAST
MAJOR THESE ARE NOT EXCITING
BILLS EXCEPT WHEN THERE'S A
PROBLEM THEY BECOME VERY
EXCITING WE HAVE THESE ALL
THESE VARIOUS R. P. S.'S AND
STANDARDS CHANGING THE LIKE.
MIES VAN DE ROHE THE GREAT
ARCHITECT SAID GOD IS IN THE
DETAILS THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
DETAILS BILLS THAT DOES NOT
GRAB HEADLINES BUT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT PREVENTING HEADLINES TO
MAKE SURE THAT- WE ALIGN OUR
STATE ELECTRICITY RESOURCE
PROCUREMENT ACTIVITIES WITH OUR
STATE CLEAN ENERGY RELIABILITY
GOALS SIMILAR TO THE LAST BILL
SEEKING TO TRY TO BASICALLY
FINE TUNE. THIS LARGER POLICY
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
TRANSITION TO RENEWABLES WORKS
IS RELIABLE AND COST EFFECTIVE
AS RELIABLE OKAY WILL- COME TO
THE GALLERY AND ROOM TWELVE IF
WE CAN. THE NO ONE IS A ROOM.
FULL OF ONE TWELVE. IN SUPPORT
OF UP- ONE IN THE GO INSTEAD OF
HIS BOOK THE PHONE LINES. FOR
SPEAKERS SUPPORT. S. P. SIX
FOUR SIX SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
MODERATOR PLEASE CUES. SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX FOUR SIX.
CERTAINLY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF BILL SB SIX FOUR SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
SHOW SUPPORT A BILL SB SIX FOUR
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I HAVE NO ONE IN
SUPPORT COULD YOU- SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX FOUR SIX.
CERTAINLY YOU WOULD THINK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX FOUR SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AS A REMINDER TO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. SIX FOUR SIX.
AND I'VE KNOWN OPPOSITION OKAY
WILL COME TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- WHAT IS YOUR PLEASURE.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS EMOTION WE
HAVE. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR BURGESS. US SENATORS
DID YOU WANNA MAKE A CLOSING
COMMENTS S. ARRIVAL THANK YOU.
VERY WELL WE HAVE A MOTION TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS NO I'M SORRY
TO PASS. YES DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. BUCKLER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SB SIX FOUR SIX
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG DO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL HI
WESSEL HI DALAI. BACK. DELHI
ARE THOROUGHLY I. BETTER RIGHT.
BECKER I. PERFECT PERFECT. IS A
NINE FORGES HELLO WE'RE JUST I
BRADFORD HI BRAD I DON ALL
RIGHT DON I HATE MEN. CONTROLS
HI CONTROL I GROW I GROW I
HEARD SPURRED BY HER I MIKE
WEIR HI REQUIRE. MAN HI MAN I.
RUBIO SIR. SEVEN NINE EIGHT.
VERY WELL THEN WE- SIR IS OUT
PRESENTING ANOTHER BILL SO
WE'LL GO TO SAN BRETT FOR. SAN
BRADFORD YOU COMPRESS FOR ME TO
IF YOU'RE. YOU CAN PRESENT FROM
THERE I WOULD LIKE. THANK YOU
MR I'M HERE SP
SEVEN FOUR THREE. WHICH
ESTABLISHES A GRANT PROGRAM FOR
BROADBAND ADOPTION COMPUTER
EQUIPMENT AND DIGITAL LITERACY
AND PUBLIC COLLEGE IN MAY TWO
THOUSAND AND THIRTEEN I
AUTHORED A BILL- TO CREATE A
PUBLIC HOUSING ACCOUNT- FOR THE
ADVANCE SERVICES FUN WHAT WE
FOUND OUT THAT MOST OF OUR
PUBLIC HOUSING AS- OVER. SIXTY
YEARS IT'S NOT WATER IF YOU
DRIVE BY A AVERAGE PUBLIC
HOUSING. UNITS YOU SEE A BUNCH
OF SATELLITE DISHES DISHES ON
THE SIDE OF THE BUILDINGS AND I
WAS TAKEN ABACK BY THAT ABOUT
TEN YEARS AGO ONLY TO FIND OUT.
THAT VERY FEW IF ANY OF THEM
ARE WIRED FOR INTERNET LET
ALONE CABLE- THAT ACCOUNT THAT
WE CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN- PROVIDED FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR BROADBAND ADULT
ADOPTION GRANTS. THIS PROGRAM.
WHAT'S POPULAR IT WAS FULLY
SUBSCRIBED FOR. EVEN BEFORE THE
SUNSET ATE ARRIVES- IT FUNDED
PROJECTS LIKE DATA DIGITAL IT
LITERACY AND COMPUTER SKILLS
TRAINING FOR THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE AND A SISTER PUBLICADO
RESIDENTS ACROSS THE STATE. THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IT IS A REAL
PROBLEM THIS IS JUST NOT IN A
RURAL COMMUNITY TO ITS IN URBAN
AREAS AS WELL. NO WHERE IS
THERE A CLEAR. SAMPLE THAN THAT
AND THEN A OUR PUBLIC HOUSING
PROJECTS. THIS BILL WOULD
REESTABLISH THE BROADBAND
ADOPTION GRANTS PROGRAM TO
CONTINUE TARGETING INVESTMENTS
AND SOME OF THE PLACES WHERE IT
IS MOST NEEDED- TESTIFYING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THIS MEASURE
IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE TELEVISION.
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
THOMAS CAROL MCINTYRE AND I
RESPECT THAT FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU IS CAROLYN MCINTYRE
ON THE LINE. THIS CAROLYN
MCINTYRE ON THE LINE ANYONE.
CAN ANYONE TELL ME IF. I DON'T
CARE ON THE LINE. OKAY TRAINING
FOR THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THE
PUBLIC. BUT I DON'T KNOW BY WE
HAVE A RESTAURANT ON. ONE OF
THE LAND. PROJECT COMING FROM.
ONE PM THAT CAROLYN MACAN JOINT
US ON THE PHONE. VERY WELL-
MISS MCINTYRE YOU HAVE TO
MINUTES. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND THEN CAN THAT AND BE HAPPY
THE SEAT. WE'RE HAPPY BE IN OF
THE- BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE DIVIDE- MY
OF THE BEEN ON BROAD DEPLOYMENT
CALIFORNIA HAD BEEN THE A LARGE
BROAD BUT ADOPT PROGRAM. THAT
MAY BE- GO DOWN A PATH TO
FITNESS POPULATION AND GET
CONNECT WE ARE JUST OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL NOT GO TO OF
THE PUBLIC IN. PRESS PLEASE
FOUR THREE. AND I SEE NO ONE
WHO IN THE GAL WILL GO ROOM
ONE. ANYONE ROOM HOTEL WANT TO.
ONE TWO. IF I CAN GET A LOOK AT
ONE ROOM ONE TWELVE. HIS ROOM
ONE TWELVE. HELLO FOR THE-
WORLD. FIGURATIVE ROOM ONE
TWELVE PLEASE. ONE TWELVE.
THERE YOU GO ROOM FOR NO ONE'S
THERE I HAD A CHECK SOMEHOW I
THOUGHT NOBODY WOULD BE THERE
AND I WAS RIGHT. OKAY I WILL GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON THE
PHONES IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
FOUR THREE. MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN FOUR THREE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
FOUR THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO APPETITE. WE DO HAVE ONE
ACUTE UP THERE CURRENTLY WITH
AN OPERATOR. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK AT THE PORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT ZERO AT
THIS TIME FOR SB SEVEN FOUR
THREE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. OPEN MY NUMBER TWO
ZERO NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
WELL CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THIS
CALL HOLLY CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER.
WALGREENS AND- YEAH THE- WHERE.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER SPEAKERS
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE. WE KNOW
ENOUGH TO SUPPORT. NO ONE ELSE.
NO ONE ELSE THERE OKAY CAN YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN FOUR
THREE. CERTAINLY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN FOUR
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. I ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN FOUR THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I SHOW NO ONE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY THANK YOU WILL COME BACK
TO THE FLOOR HERE FOR MEMBERS
ANY OF ANY COMMENTS CONCERNS
pAND NO ONE'S IN THE GALLERY NO
BUT I'M JUST IN THE UK I'M
SORRY. THE CENTRE BECKER. MY
PLEASURE TO SAY THAT- REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS BUILT THIS IS
SO IMPORTANT I WAS ON THE BOARD
OF A NONPROFIT WHEN CONNIE FOR
MANY YEARS HAD TO BRING IT HOME
CAMPAIGN- FOR BROADBAND ACCESS
I JUST HAD A QUESTION IT IS.
THERE'S A G. BECAUSE FOR YOUR-
OF. BUT THE AN EXISTING.
PROGRAM DID YOU CONSIDER
FINDING THE SYSTEM PROGRAMS
JUST NEW PROGRAM GONNA BE
DIFFERENT THAN THE- CAN CAN
EXISTING- CASF PROGRAM. THIS
MEASURE IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN FOR PUBLIC HOUSING AND
WE EXPENDED ALL THE FONTS AND
THIS WILL BE A CONTINUATION OF
THE PROGRAM THAT WE STARTED TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN GOT A
PHYSICAL CONTINUATION OCCURS
WHEN TUCKER THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THIRTY ONE OTHERS ANYONE ELSE.
COULD WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SANDRA
GONZALEZ. AND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CLARK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL NO CLOSED. IF YOU
WANT TO CLOSE THE G. ONE X. PUT
ON IT SORRY ABOUT THAT I. WE
DON'T RESPECT ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU FOR MUCH- BUT THAT'S
EXACTLY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SEVEN FOUR THREE BY SENATOR
BRADFORD DO AND WE WILL TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATE.
WESSEL WAS UP BY DOLLY HI DOLLY
NINE THANK. HI BECKER I FORGES
I FOR JUST HI BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HI THOUGHT. DONE I
HATE MEN. GONZALEZ I THE LIST
HI GREW I. CAN I GROW HI.
HERTZBERG HI. HI MIKE WEIR.
MAKE WIRE I. MAN. MAN I RUBIO.
TURN. ELEVEN A STIR. THANK YOU
THE COMMITTEE THE BILL IS OUT
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE BILL
LEFT BUT THE AUTHOR IS NOT
PRESENT. HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
TO PRESENT HER BILL SO- WE WILL
WHAT WE'LL DO IS TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY GET MEMBERS TO ADD
ON TO BILLS- THAT ARE STILL
OPEN SO WE WILL BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE S. P. SIX ONE
TWO. CLICK PLEASE CALL THE
OPPOSITE NUMBERS. AT THREE SIX
ONE TWO BY SENATOR PART AND
TINA TO PASS AS AMENDED. WESSEL.
FIVE ONE SEVEN FOUR FOUR FIVE
SEVEN POLICE PROTECTION GROWTH
I. WELL OFF OF SOME. A MASS OF.
AND. YEAH ALL I KNOW THE- GIRL
I GOT TO KNOW. MCGUIRE REQUIRE
FIVE STERN. ONE OF SURE THAT'S
TEN DAYS AND ONE NO AND THAT'S
A MEMBER WHOSE ACTION ON THAT
BILL SENATOR STERN OKAY. OKAY
WE'LL GO TO ITEM NUMBER TWO IS
B. SIX ONE SEVEN. CLARK PLEASE
CALL THE OFFICE OF MEMBERS. SP
SIX ONE SEVEN BY SENATOR WIENER
TO PASS AS AMENDED. FORGES. NO
FOR JUST NOW. REQUIRE REQUIRE.
FIVE YEAH. SEMOGA ARE YOU
VOTING ON THIS BILL. OKAY SURE
THAT'S ALWAYS INTO THOSE. ALSO
THAT WE CAN CLOSE THAT BUILDING
SHOVEL CLOSE AS P. SIX ONE SO.
ON THE CONSENT. THE CLERK
PLEASE CALL MEMBERS IMAGES
CALENDAR. CONSENT CALENDAR
GROVE. CAN PROVIDE I. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG I MCGUIRE. MIKE WEIR
I. RUBIO PEOPLE. THIRTEEN ZERO
SHARE LIMITS MEMBERSHIP THE
ROLE OF THE TRAPS OF MEMBERS
WILL GO NOW TO. FOR ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SP. THREE SEVEN EIGHT FOUR
PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE OF
MEMBERS. SP THREE SEVEN EIGHT
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ DO PASS AS
AMENDED. EIGHT MEN. EIGHT MEN I.
STERN. SHARES THIRTEEN EIGHTIES.
OKAY WILL CALL THE ROLL PIN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WILL MOVE NOW TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SP. FIVE TO
NINE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE OF
MEMBERS. S. FIVE TO NINE BY
SENATOR. HURTS BIRDS DO PASS.
FIGMENT. THREE FIVE TWO NINE
HERTZBERG. THE CENTER AGAIN HI
HI SHE'S A NINETY EIGHT WHEN I.
THIRD THIRTEEN A STIR THEY WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OF THE PRESS
MEMBERS I'D FOLLOW HIM SIX
FIFTY SIX FOUR SIX BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG WORK PLEASE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS SP SIX FOUR SIX
BISON HERTZBERG DO PASS AIKMAN.
EIGHT MEN HI. RUBIO STERN. TOP
AIDES. OKAY WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE
PERHAPS A MEMBER ON I DON'T
KNOW NINE AS PEACE FOUR. BY
SOME BRAD PARK CALL THE UPS
MEMBER. S. B. C. FOUR THREE BY
BRADFORD DO PASS EIGHT MEN.
EIGHT I. WE'LL BE. MR STRONG
STERN HI. THIRTEEN A STIR. OKAY
WE'LL KEEP THE EYES ARE THE
APPS AND MEMBER OF THE WE HAVE
ONE OKAY- THEN WE'LL KEEP THE
ROAD OPEN ON SB SEVEN FOUR
THREE DO WE HAVE AUTHORIZATION
TO HAVE- CENTER FOR PRESENT ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR RUBIO. IN
ORDER TO. CINEMAGOERS WHO
WANTED TO- THEY WERE. C. K.
PERMISSION SHOULD BE BACK IN
THE MID. OKAY THEN WE'LL- THREE
COMES THERE IS THAT A YES YES-
I GOT IT I DON'T NEED THAT I
GOT I GOT THE STUFF I CAN SIR.
OKAY HERTZBERG PRESENT ON
BEHALF OF. RUBIO HONEST PEOPLE
SIX. PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR PRESENT BUT. FIVE AS
WE TREND IS WITH OF THIS COME
YEAR AFTER YEAR INTO CLEAN
ENERGY. WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO
DEAL WITH THE RICH POOR DIVIDE
IN WHERE WE HAVE PEOPLE IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE JUST AN EXTRAORDINARY
BURDEN ON THEMSELVES BUT ON
THEIR FAMILIES TO WITH RESPECT
TO- THE COST OF ENERGY IN FACT.
IN CALIFORNIA- BUT LOW INCOME
FAMILIES MONTHLY GROSS INCOME
GOES TOWARDS ENERGY COSTS IS
JULIE TWICE THE MEDIUM OF THE
REGIONAL MEDIA IT'S PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT SECONDLY ARM AS WE
TRY TO TRANSITION TOWARD A MORE
CLEAN ENVIRONMENT WHAT THIS
THIS BILL WILL CREATE A PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION. TO ASSIST
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WANT TO
TRANSITION TO LOW CARBON
EMITTING APPLIANCES
HISTORICALLY MISTER CHAIRMAN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIESHAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY SHOULDERED
THE BURDEN OF POOR ADULTS-
QUALITY AND HIGH ENERGY COSTS
AS WE MOVE TOWARD MEET OUR
GOALS ARE CLEAN ENERGY MANDATES
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
EMPOWER LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
TO LEAD THE CHARGE I ASKED FOR
SUPPORT SEN RUBIO'S MEASURE
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE A SPEAKER
A LEAD SPEAKER IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE READ ADDIS'S WITH.
THE CENTRAL CLOSE ENERGY
SERVICES. AND IS HE THE LINE OF
WE YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN RE
ADDICTS YEAH SINCE ENTERED G.
SERVICES. PROCRASTINATE SHE IN
A NOT FOR PROFIT OR- THAT
PROVIDES UTILITY ASSISTANCE
CONSUME EDUCATION AND ENERGY
CONSERVATION SERVICES IN
MONTEREY SAN BENITO SANTA CRUZ
AND SAN MATEO COUNTIES. MMHM
ONE OF THE MANY ENERGY'S.
PROVIDER THROUGHOUT THE STATE
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS WHY HE
PROVIDERS. THE COMMUNITIES WE
WORK IN WANT TO BE PART OF
TACKLING CLIMATE CHANGE WHEN A
PARTNER WITH THE STATE TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES IN
THEIR OWN HOMES BY TAKING
DIRECT ACTIONS. IN THIS CASE
THIS GRANT. PROGRAM WOULD ALLOW.
INDIVIDUALS TO A- ASSESS PRESS.
TO ELIMINATE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION ASSIST WITH THEIR-
IT'S FOR THOSE WERE. TO SUPPORT
THE MEASURE. WE ALSO THINK THE
FOR THIS. PROGRAM. MAKE FOR
THIS PROGRAMME RATHER ELAINE
WELL WITH WITH THIS BLUE IS
GOING ON IN BUDGET AS WELL
SHARES FELL AS THE SEVENTY. FOR
THOSE REASONS WHICH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK SO NOW GO TO
SPEAK. IN SOME. OF S. B. FIVE
SIXTY NO ONE. HAS TO BE PRESENT
HERE AND THE GUY. ONE TWELVE NO
ONE IS FOR THERE. WE WILL GO TO
THE LINE SMALL FOR YOU PLEASE
CUES AS SUPPORT OF SB. FIVE
SIXTY. CERTAINLY THE LADY AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
AT TE OF S. FIVE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT THE OUT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SIXTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I SHOW NO ONE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NO ONE IS HERE IN THE
GALLERY OR IN ONE ROOM TWELVE
SO WE'LL GO TO SPEAKERS. IN
OPPOSITION THERE IS NO
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE SIXTY
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE SIXTY. IF YOU WANT TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE SIXTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
SHOW NO ONE IN OPPOSITION. VERY
WELCOME BACK TO THE FLOOR
SENATOR HERTZBERG IF YOU WANT
TO JUST TAKE TO THE MIKE THERE
JUST IN CASE ANY OF ANY ON HAND
IT DOES ANY QUESTIONS AND I
JUST WANT TO GET YOU TO CONFIRM
THAT I MEAN YOU'RE THIS IS KIRK
TECHNICALLY FOR THE MOMENT YOUR
BILL SO IF YOU WANT TO MAKE
AMENDMENTS TO IT. WE CAN
DISCUSS THAT RIGHT NOW CAN I
ADD A- PROVISION ON BAIL- WELL
WE COULD- TO GET YOU ON THE-
THIS- HAVE SOME OR PROPOSED THE
COMMITTEE THE AUTHOR. OF A FORM
ME I HAVE A HEARD HER- ROOM
NOTE SAID UP TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THEM SHE SAID THE MINUTES. I
JUST WANT TO GET YOU TO FOR THE
RECORD THAT YOU X. THOSE MEN.
YES SIR MANY MEMBERS. OUR X.
SHE WE JUST A CHECK. TO MAKE
SURE. YES AND THOSE AMENDMENTS
ARE CLARIFIES- SERVICE- CLEARLY
STATE THE NEED FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE APPROPRIATION TO
FUND THE PROGRAM AND NEAR THE
LIST OF ELIGIBLE USES TO THOSE
CONSISTENT WITH THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT TO TARGET APPLIANCES
THAT HELP RESIDENTS RESEARCH
REDUCE FUTURE. AND REQUIRE THE
CST TO ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM
IN CONSULTATION. WITH THE C. E.
C. THOSE WHO THEY ARE- YES SIR
IF IT IS MEANT BY THE AUTHOR
OKAY VERY WELL CAN I JUST SENT
AT THE TOP OF THE POINT THAT
YOU WERE IN HER YOU CAN NOTE
THAT IT SETTING CLOSEST ON THIS
WEEK COME BACK TO THE FROM. AND
IF COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR EMOTION-
STERN SENATOR STERN IS HERE.
FOR CENTER TURN- YOUR BACK. YES
I AM SORRY MISTER CHAIR DID YOU
WANT SAY SOMETHING ON THIS BILL
I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE THE
MILITANT GROUP. AND I ALSO.
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE EITHER THEY
SHOULD MAKE CREATED THE FOR
STREAM. THE END THEORY THIS
WOULD. AUGMENTED LOWER WORK
ALONGSIDE WITH A WANTED TO. SHE
MADE HIS WORK ALIGNING THIS
FAILED TO MAINTAIN HAS BEEN
SEVENTY. WHERE IS STILL. EIGHT
LECTURE CHEAT ON- WATER ISN'T
IT DOES HELLO LOW INCOME PEOPLE
YEP THERE'S YOU GREAT AT C. S.
ON BOARD THANKS FOR THE REFINE
OF THE FOCUS HELP YOU. YOU WANT
TO CLOSING COMMENTS I WOULD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST HAD
AN OPTION TO VIEW SOME OF THE
NOTES THAT. SENATOR RUBIO HAD I
THOUGHT THEY WERE TOO IMPORTANT
POINTS TO INCLUDE THE RECORD
FIRST. TWELVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
PROPERLY BENEFITED APPLIANCES
ARE ROUTINELY EXPOSED TO
NITROGEN DIOXIDE LEVELS IN
THEIR HOMES IT WOULD EXCEED
FEDERAL AND STATE HEALTH BASED
STANDARDS IF FOUND OUTSIDE OF
THE HOME. I THINK THAT PROVIDES
A COMPELLING ARGUMENT WITH
RESPECT TO HER MEASURE SECONDLY
EQUALLY TROUBLING ENERGY COSTS
TO CONSUMERS ARE PREDICTED TO
INCREASE BETWEEN 6230% BY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO NEXT YEAR
AGAIN ANOTHER COMPELLING
ARGUMENT THAT I WANT TO PUT THE
RECORD WITH THAT. I ASK FOR AN
IDOL TO BE HAVE SENT A REVIEW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION. THE CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SB FIVE SIXTY BY
SENATOR RUBIO DO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST THE MANTA AND
WE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL ALL
RIGHT. RESERVED BY THE DALAI.
BECKER HI BECKER I FORGES.
BRADFORD HI RADFORD I DON I DON
I BIG WIN. BIG WIN HI CLOSE ALL
THIS HI GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I REQUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI MAN. MAN HI RUBIO.
STERN. STARTING STERN HI. SURE
THAT'S TEN DAYS OKAY- ON WHICH
BILLS ARE WE TOO WE HAVE
MEMBERS MISSING BECAUSE I KNOW
WE HAVE- ONE WHAT ELSE WE HAVE
SENATOR STERN MISSING. FOR AN
INCOME. SB SIX TALL LET'S-
BRING UP SP SIX TWELVE. AND
CALL THE OPTION MEMBERS. SB SIX
TWELVE BY SENATOR PART INTO YOU
KNOW TO PASS AS AMENDED STERN.
TRY STERN HI. ARE THERE ANY
MISSING MEMBERS ON SP. SIX
TWELVE. ELEVEN A IS ONE NOW THE
GOAL OF OKAY THEN WE'LL CLOSE A
ROLAND SP SIX TWELVE I THINK WE
ALREADY CLOSE ROLES HONESTLY SP
SIX SEVENTEEN. FINANCER WILL.
DO WE HAVE A SENATOR IGMAN
MISSING ON ANY BILLS. OKAY.
OKAY. ABOUT SENATOR MCGUIRE.
OKAY SENATOR STERN ARE YOU
STILL THERE. I AM ME I THINK
YOU'RE MISSING ON A FEW OTHER
BILLS SO- MONICA COULD YOU-
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO. I
REMEMBER FOR SP THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT BY CENTER GONZALEZ.CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE OF
MEMBERS ON AS B. THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT. FIFTY THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR GONZALEZ TO
PASS AS AMENDED STERN. ONE
AMIDST TRAINING ON. YOUR
STATEMENT YES OKAY THEN WE'LL
GO TO- NUMBER FIVE SP FIVE TO
NINE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG.
ANOTHER QUICK PHYSICALLY UP TO
MEMBERS. SP FIVE TO NINE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG TO PASS STERN.
RIGHT SEVEN NINE FOURTEEN ETS
CHECK CABLE CLOSER ROLE ON ITEM
FOR. AND WE'LL CLOSE ROLE ON
ITEM FIVE AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
ITEM SIX SP SIX FOUR SIX BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG PLEASE CALL
THE OPTION MEMBERS. SB SIX FOUR
SIX BY SENATOR HERTZBERG DO
PASS RUBIO. STERN STRONG THIRTY
FIVE THIRTEEN A STRIP. OKAY.
OKAY I THINK THAT COVER SENATOR
STERN. FOR ANY INTEREST. THREE
SEVEN FORTY THREE. YOU IT WOULD
APPEAR THAT HE HAS SCORED OKAY
LET'S START. OKAY LISTENERSHIP
SPRING.
YEAH. YEAH.
JUST FOR
THE PUBLIC'S BENEFIT I JUST
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THOSE THAT WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SICK OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING FOR THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATION. OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WHEN ONE
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HERE IN RECORDS THANK
YOU. AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. WE'RE GONNA TAKE
UP A FIVE MINUTE RECESS AND
THEN WE'LL RE RE CONVEY BEING.
IN FIVE MINUTES.
WELCOME BACK
TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS WHICH TOOK FIVE
MINUTE BREAK WE'RE BACK. WE'RE
GONNA COME AND FINISH OFF OF
THE VOTES ON OUR CALENDAR
TODAY. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH ITEM WITH S. P. SIX FOUR
SIX. AND I'D LIKE TO ASK THE
CLERK TO PLEASE CALL THE COPS
AND MEMBERS OF. SB SIX FOUR SIX.
SB SIX FOUR SIX BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. DO PASS REVIEW HI
REVIEW BY ITS FOURTEEN ACER.
THANK YOU WILL DOUBLE CHECK SP.
FIVE SIX ZERO CALL THE OPTION
MEMBERS. SB FIVE SIXTY BY
SENATOR RUBIO DO PASS AS
AMENDED. FIVE DELHI. FORTIS
GROVE RUBIA HI REVEALED BY.
THAT'S ELEVEN ACER OKAY WE'RE
CLOSER ROLE- WILL GO DOWN A
LITTLE CULTURAL AND S. P. SIX
FOUR SIX WILL CLOSE ROLAND SP
FIVE SIXTY- CLARK WILL GO TO A-
SB SEVEN FOUR THREE PLEASE CALL
THE OFFICE OF MEMBERS ON SB
SEVEN FOUR THREE. SB SEVEN FOUR
THREE BY SENATOR BRADFORD. TO
PASS. RUBIO I REVIEW HI IT'S
FOURTEEN EASTER. WE'LL CLOSE
ROLAND SEVEN FOUR THREE WILL GO
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SB
SEVEN THIRTY THREE ON CONSENT.
WILLIAM HI RUBIO HI. FOURTEEN A
STIR VERY WELL THAT BRINGS US
TO THE END OF OUR CALENDAR WILL
CLOSE TO ROLLING ALL THE BILLS
ALL THE BILLS ARE SUCCESSFULLY
OUT WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THOSE
POLLED TODAY. SO WE AGAIN WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
CHILES AND COMMUNICATIONS IS
NOW ADJOURNED. COOL.